[Music]
thank you
good afternoon
in the realm what's going on here
[Music]
no that's the craziest start I've ever
seen anything
[Music]
popping off web day what's going on
brother Joe Mac OG what's going on these
guys find out some chat the new name for
the toxic fanboy antique gamer no more
credit for being a fan of games clearly
you hate me hashtag anti-gameless I feel
that yeah a lot of dudes don't celebrate
actually playing games and enjoying them
you know what I'm saying like dude is
busy telling you why you shouldn't be
having fun and not play a game I'm with
that OG I'm with that great area what's
going on Robert Kelly
[Music]
eight days later and feeling great
exercise let's go Health as well let's
get it Mexican
[Music]
a lot of fun topics can you be full
enough
[Music]
we got some nice topics lined up for
y'all know that IMAX what's going on
okay RF what's up no doubts and let me
give you salute salute appreciate it
appreciate it so we will be back
Carolina game between the crib no doubt
thanks again
[Music]
Queen Beezy salute sis how we doing
in here
[Music]
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Fred and Kruger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that yoga fire plane they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless and people don't aim check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my CD but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
oh
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start it regardless and
people don't aim check my vocals all on
Twitter social or my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
uses the target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my CD but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear me man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all that good stuff that we
need to do in um you know we're about to
get started I am well it's not important
who I am uh what's important is that you
are pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
damn look You Oughta messed up and
turned me to an animal and headers be
swearing ain't real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
I'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beating they
wanna compare me to Freddie and Jason
I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I'm addicted to flipping and Sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is the Yoga Fire Flame they think
it's Arsen up in the apartment they call
a department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing ain't real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up into your apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain uses
the target when I'm in the range I was
the hardest to start with regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you that's
[Music]
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
videos
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to an ebender I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnido who cares if he flies you
stealing mosquito you swear you ain't
nothing but really be Stevo you like to
collect stuff and that's cool but I got
bad news even if he really was that joke
he ain't never still be the king of the
statue sister juvenile I've been cursed
with a curse to be Musical and if you
hate it we'll meet in The Crucible other
than nothing it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord today
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
videos
and all that good stuff
the little little Mike Mike check your
check let me make sure to hear the king
in the ending what's going on yeah yeah
hello hello hello yeah yeah it was low
for me yeah actually actually no saying
he's talking hello hello hello there you
go there you go smooth he's doing that
lean back thing yeah
Stephanie casual addicts
you'd be like all right guys
it was funny I was talking when I was
talking to him thank you what's up and
he was like you got to keep doing that
spin the chair thing that's you I always
thought if I said
all right look like the levels is good
and all that here ye hear ye and we are
live who's that live Supremacy oh what's
going on bro salute and welcome to the
online podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 321
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's date
and today we've got Mortal Kombat one
unity's new pricing model
PlayStation state of play
that's gonna be interesting Nintendo
switch direct oh Xbox Tokyo game show
and square enix's future to discuss yeah
that should be interesting
so we gonna get right into it so let's
introduce the full hold on one two three
what's going on we got we got one
message don't you love how like Carlton
like he acts like he went live and just
forgot to look and see if there's four
yeah what's going on is this somebody
did we do that in Sesame Street hey hey
guys it's different something's
different can you point out what's
different boys and girls what are these
kids
what are these kids
can you say songs here
all right kids so look our brother is
coming he is uh on Route everything is
fine coming in hot coming in hot is Lord
Sovereign straight from uh I ain't gonna
put his business out but he's coming
he's coming through he's coming through
so don't worry don't worry but we still
got the other Horseman you know what I'm
saying in the realm my co-host with the
combos well somebody remembers the
Sesame my brother from another mother
the difficult getting conqueror Lord of
his old world and the how of the young
wolf my man Lord attic back to back with
the spinning Rooney attic show what's
going on
pretty good man I have been up for for a
whole two hours oh you too he's putting
in the kids just got my water yeah
I'll hold the line coin I need the
inspiration man
there you go that Meme where they're
holding the coin like this yes with the
um what you talking about the one with
the priest one the one today yeah yeah
you're gonna get that water y'all you'll
get that water he right back don't worry
about that yeah so that that's pretty
much it man you know it's been died back
to back
messing around it's uh been playing been
playing Mortal Kombat for a couple hours
deep thoughts for the trumpet hold on so
where the hell's sovereign
it's about to be a ride at least
I'm about to get this work when he come
back yeah so I know you watching you
better Rectify your matters
she's doing a Mortal Kombat what else
he's doing I've been playing the crew
I've been trying to get back talk about
that yeah we can talk about it okay yeah
we've been trying to get into
um
back into other games you know what's
funny I had to uninstall Starfield just
to play anything else why why is that
because every time I think that mid game
out and and what is it doing to you
every time I went to play something else
I did I don't know how man I just turned
uh like next thing you know I'm I'm on
Starfield like editing a [__]
it's like yeah I gotta get rid of this
so it's officially been deleted I feel
yeah I can't do that but I understand
what you're saying because it's it was
tough for me to play other games it's
getting to that point when I put it in
first
I it won't stop if you just you'll find
something to do and occupy it so I know
where you at it and it's just like I was
like I gotta play these other games
first I cannot if I throw Starfield on I
will get myself all up into an adventure
and doing all type of crazy so I feel
you there but yeah I got you so you was
rocking the crew though
yeah I've played a good amount of the
crew over the weekend it's uh very
interesting game uh we have uh content
creation or revolved around it so gotta
figure out how we're uh gonna do that
but you know it's it's definitely
interesting one thing I am trying to
finish is I'm finally trying to finish
Persona 5.
I'm on like what like you know at the
beginning of persona you start in the
palace it's like a future thing and you
go back into the past and explain how
you got there yeah I'm in that Palace
so I'm kind of curious like how that is
but then I'm like man you know I gotta
delete star film and somehow I ended up
on uh you know the crew and then I turn
around and now on my Mortal Kombat it's
just been 2023 can end just so I could
stop playing so many games back to back
back shout out disguise he said uh yeah
IOP Starfield is like the record store
you just gonna pop in next thing you
know you've been digging in through the
crate for two hours
back though that's a fact though let's
go to Astro parrot what's going on I got
the poster yeah that post is fire so
that's been it sir yeah that's pretty
much it yeah it's been a a very hectic
week I feel yeah for you no doubt and of
course you know what technical gaming
Lord is on Route he will be here but we
still got the Incredible Hulk of this
aka the access gamer the prophet and
Morpheus of Xbox Swami King of the
statues he develops nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the whole the line movement
love it Lord King how are we doing sir
I'ma tell you
I am dead tired yeah but there was so
much stuff this week like I think it was
talking about the crew yeah um I'm
looking at direct again I found out
yesterday that Mario Super Mario
Brothers streaming on peacock so I
watched that again yesterday
um I'm on some of the old Nintendo High
um you know because I had to watch the
show again because I was like these
dudes just don't miss they they you know
sometimes they do a a Pokemon Direct and
you know that kind of you know spreads
you know the crowd to the left for the
right you know depending on if you're a
Pokemon fan so when they do shows like
this that has everything now I'm down
for all of this yeah
um but that four out of ten shows
don't forget the multi Flats don't
forget the gravy you realize a lot of
that show was e for everyone oh yeah
another sudden I never said Nintendo was
it wasn't me for everyone
have for one platform I got you yeah
dude that's the only smoke I got I only
got smoke for one platform because they
like the exclusive and they like to
count numbers so I'm waiting for their
numbers to go away exclusive to
disappear I'm doing it that's what I do
[Laughter]
yeah I was playing a couple of things I
feel like you with the Starfield and the
Fortnight my joint is I sit down and I'm
I'm actively hunting the skin in
fortnite and I said let me go check the
store to see if the skin is there then
they have some new stuff in there and
I'm like oh what's this it's a new dance
let me see the dance and then I said you
know what I can I can get one quick game
in real quick yep there you go and
fortnite then took over my time my
whatever three hours I had it was all in
fortnite then I'm trying to get over to
Starfield and then if I could it's just
either or whoever gets turned on first
is is the winner gets forgotten and then
don't don't get me started on games that
I have to play like if if we got games
in review I gotta play them so I can
give my opinion of these games so
that that's rough because half the time
you don't want to play them
are you sitting there like okay man
would you hurry up if you but you can't
skip cut scenes you can't skip certain
things that are vital you gotta listen
and watch and learn so it is probably
the most arduous process in getting a
new game to review that maybe you're not
all that greatly interested in and you
have some super anticipated stuff right
here that you want to play so The
Balancing Act is crazy you know you're
right you're absolutely right because
that joint is like especially when
you know something is about to come out
you know you got to cover it you got to
review it but you so in pocket with what
you've been playing and now you gotta
stop that funny black all right and
nothing worse if what you about to
review or whatever is not as popular as
what you've been for yes so now you're
like now you're looking at the reviews
you're like man I had to get myself
mentally out of that so I got so I could
be fair to the review Drake but I know
what you talking about yeah yeah that's
how I felt yesterday and I was like I
had to um bring it back because I was
gonna skip or something that was
happening I was like no no no yeah you
got to go through the whole process this
is totally different take your take
yourself out of this in fact because I
did want to jump back on Starfield
because I was doing something that I
shouldn't be doing and I was having
success doing it I was like let me save
right here because it looked like it's
about to go left
that's come save right before you
already know so that's been it that's it
no doubt King check the yo check out IOP
chat when you get a chance okay guys no
doubt and of course we have the gaming
ninja himself the lean beefy you know we
we normally beefy yet it's like
cognito's friend never listen to the
Roman IOP not tell you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear shout out
to Mr Maddie play Shout out to finding
Duke talking about that star field
launch success I might have been a
little messy on that one it might have
been a little messy they wanted it they
want it it's like God but we gonna get
it let's get a little bit so go check
that out a little fun we'll talk about
that UK consoles attach rate crazy
engagement all that stuff a lot of fun a
lot of good episodes there shout out to
the last World he bought this time I got
Travis talk about reviews all the new
Sandbox currency changes and Destiny and
right now they got a lot of glitches
going on Sir this is crazy stuff going
on with Dusty right now people shooting
Rockets out shotguns like guns
misbehaving I think there's like some
crafting glitch or something but shout
out to bungee for getting ahead of it
and talk about yeah they're gonna leave
it and then they they're not gonna roll
back and they're gonna do some other
stuff to fix it so salute to them as far
as me obviously Mortal Kombat but I will
get into depth when we uh talk about you
know talk about it later the topic
Starfield I've been questing crazy
um really trying to clean up now some
faction quests I'm doing some
achievement hunting
um addict can be proud of me man I'm out
here about here stealing ships finally
finally I just now getting to that to
that joint but I want to give you a
shout out um for putting me on to the
ryujin ship line that one you told me
about yeah that one is nice so I think
it costs like almost like what 450 000
that [__] actually that [__] cost a lot
but um yeah 300 and it's 420 000 if you
don't have any of the social
um you know uh the social skill where
you can negotiate on price yeah I don't
got that so they hit me I think I paid
380. you pay 380. yeah they saw me they
was like full price for you I was like
okay but uh due to uh my bad attic
hooking me up man it's it's Buddy out
here in these streets for those that
know
there is money out here
there's a lot of money to be had in
Starfield vet if you ain't on it you
better find out because bethesda's gonna
be coming soon
it's that crazy shout out to new
Atlantis though shout out to do Atlantis
um anyway you're doing that trick I
don't know what you're listening I don't
know
I don't know what you talking about the
the [__] was on sale just happened to be
on sale when I came through you know
check the chat I'm just saying you know
we just came through
the Street's made out of money you just
gotta know where it's at yeah no no no
no yes I'll be doing that and uh oh yeah
somebody said literally money in the
street like yeah look man I can't put
that business out akw I never saw this
and they said I don't know what he
talked about I just how did the dude
find that listen there's a wallet
somebody left their wallet in a certain
spots
we had to get down under the screen
under the bottom how did he do that what
put his brain to that the same the same
thing you can do in like Skyrim and
stuff so people knew that stuff they
knew how Bethesda does their games and
maybe other companies that do these type
of games do the same way so they knew
that they knew they could just glitch in
the map they can find those those chats
akw man it's just just Google it do
Atlantis and see the things that may
happen and come up see what's going on
over there but there's other spots to
these other spots the streets
that's by far the best but that's by far
the best wallet you could find
literally yeah people out here just in
new Atlantis do it right you can get
like probably a hundred grand every like
10 minutes yo still chairs he said fraud
alert on the Lord
I beat the game listen man I I just I
just I'm just one of those guys that
happened to find things I'm just very
lucky with finding money on the ground
but um anyway that's that's what it is
called you just somehow you fell through
the ground you saw chess it was it was
what it was but anyway I do not approve
the hotel can't get smoking no no other
than that big racing weekend for me you
know it all started up with a Forza
Motorsport obviously shout out to um
shout out to kick David holding it down
you know I'm saying I turned 10
interview you know what I'm saying we
did that was incredible incredible man
Chris I'm very proud of what we did with
Chris's eye yeah that's really good
questions in that thank you thank you
like and it was just fun man shot being
able one of one of adding though one of
my bucket list is always to like to get
every Studio whether it be yours
PlayStation Studios Xbox game studio and
we get there with Xbox games first time
I ever interviewed turned 10 before I
felt like when I when I edit our stuff
and especially interviews and like
like really hard questions are asked
always get like like a nervous chill up
my spine yeah what'd they do here
but ironically like they weren't really
holding punches like they answered
everything yeah they were ready for the
smoke because one thing I learned in
past interviews you know what I'm saying
is about you know Hardware specific
questions but King as we know when we
walked up in there we felt the level of
transparency yeah felt like yo what oh
no this series X is right here you want
to capture everything was right there
what you want to do
yes everyone gets a series that yeah
shout out to shout out to turn 10 shout
out to Chris Rocky highly highly advised
if you have not watched our interview it
is up on the I love podcast YouTube
Channel interview section it's up on
launchgaming.net go check it out on the
earth yeah yo I had a lot of fun with
that one he was he was down on Earth he
was cool you listen I fanboyed out when
I saw Dan yeah
that's the first time I've ever fanboyed
out on an exact like it was crazy but
and we was going to do an interview with
him too but we were just like nah we
already got the interview Chris it would
have been kind of redundant to be honest
with you but we did ask him some
questions behind it you know yeah that
was really good and we was able to get
the um the picture man that I'm glad you
you remember reminded me to do that
because he he doesn't come outside a lot
in my opinion you know yeah that not
Chris um Dan Dan yeah it's also the fact
that sometimes you be in the moment you
forget yeah you got it and I was like no
no I can't forget dude I needed a
picture with him yeah love that man
awesome Nicholas Archie so Louie said
bro I love this podcast so much it
brings me so much joy whenever Sunday
IOP salute that's love salute salute and
thank you for the alternative love
everybody but yeah so that's that and
then um so that was racing for the
beginning of the week playing the
preview but rocking getting my
qualifying on again check out our
impressions of that we got very detailed
Impressions up on that as well as Lords
of gaming.net shot my man might move a
fantastic article go check it out and
then um the next racing I don't know if
he told me was the crew I got thoughts I
got thoughts you want me to hold it
until soft you know we just go go yeah
and then okay yeah all right so I'll
hold back those with salt comes and
we'll all talk his group about it yeah
we got to be transparent too yeah yeah
Ubisoft send us all cups to try out the
game so absolutely just to let you guys
know I'm gonna pay full shield bro you
know the check came in come on man you
see you see these breakfasts I'm doing
we will fun we well
what's your talking points for the day
addict you've been upgrading from uh
from General King to NDA General King
we're gonna you need us we need you to
sign this piece of paper on your way out
the door
everything is a clearance for
all right so here's
I gotta I gotta I got I gotta put this
up now Nintendo
I owe y'all apology all right I owe your
apology
um King you know how I feel about f-zero
like that's one of the few games when
with Mo with them early most seven games
as soon as you saw it as soon as you
invited me to the crib you got I got the
super famicom come through I think I
brought us with me that day yeah almost
came there yeah and we sat there he had
the pile of wings he had that joint it
was you had three some other joint we
had problems act crazy yeah and I saw
the scaling
I said
dance
kid because I was talking rare records
with memory was because it was Genesis
16 bit and regular Nintendo and it was
mud stomping regular dude
so as a Sega kid it was popping though
man when I saw that I said hey
oh no so I go for I did not want to
leave your house I was like I came back
to my house with disgust with the side
highlights
anyway so yeah f-zero yo that mean a lot
to me and um obviously the direct we saw
they got to do once called episode 99 so
when I first saw it I was like yeah they
doing dismissed it battle Roy what they
doing like I was like oh so I was like
oh it was like the The Godfather was
like look how they Mexican my boy I was
like let me do that so what saved me is
at the end of The Joint they go yo um if
you were Nintendo online subscriber
that's that's free 99. so I said okay I
better tell you all live so let me give
that a joint hit that up so first thing
let's check that old feeling bro once
your title screen hit and they got that
music yeah I was like oh that's the
music that was the music yeah I was like
that's that's the music I was at King's
house I was like that was it that's how
I felt so I'm seeing it I'm like all
right so you got the little practice
they got the the bumpers with the with
the drift the [__] you know the Leaning
they got the lean in left bumper right
bump I'm like all right cool they let
you practice they got the Boost you know
what I'm saying all right cool then they
got this new joint where like you do
this the 360 spin of ruling and because
remember everything in that game if you
bump into something is damaged if you're
bump in the the track is damn so now and
then remember when you pass the Finish
Line you go into the little pit stop and
then you heal up you remember that so
they got that but now as everything gets
bumped up one of the cars you do this
360 spinning ruler you could caught an
injure other cars
yeah and KO so I'm just like all right
cool so I'm getting in but the game
changer to me is they got this joint
where it's like almost like it's like
catch-up mechanic so in the back the
back of the races be like these yellow
are you talking about the joint that's
at the top yeah but you got to earn it
you got to earn it so it's this little
yellow bumper car that come out this
little Pace card usually towards the
back of the race with people who in the
back so when you see it you gotta bump
it and then it drops these little
pellets right you get the pellets and
they fill up your your Boost speeder if
your Jordans all the way feel you press
that then you go on this like Skyway and
you can skip everybody bro it's one of
those ways that you get that is if like
when when they bump into each other like
other ships it uh it will throw with a
little thing the little yeah the little
yellow dots bro that mechanic is so fire
that I ain't gonna front like so you
racing with like 100 people and then as
the laps are going on they'll be like yo
75 limo if you ain't in this 75 you're
about to get limo you better get into
75th Place no for the rest of the rate
like it's just concentration so you
battling everybody me everybody being
sheisty you know what I'm saying then
you try y'all can we do a community
that's what I want to do the only thing
I think how we could hustle an addicts
get out my number what you can what you
mean I can't be giving away my Social
Security oh no no don't give out your
Social Security but what you do I think
because how we could because you know
what Nintendo ain't got no dedicated
server so what we could do is they got
these Grand Prix events for the whole
community and they don't fill up they
run they run them like every 15 20
minutes and if they don't fill up they
just put bots so I guess we could be
like yo because it's on the Nintendo
starting screen it tells you you can
race you could do regular and then you
could do the Grand Prix yeah with a
series of five races tournament almost
like Motorola from Turbo Graphics where
you do the tournament I am telling you
they got it they got it it's fun right
it was the thing I didn't know I needed
them adding Battle Royale to f-zero was
the thing I didn't know I need it is
absolutely I didn't mean I had to
bending you on Twitter I was like yeah
they got me
I was like y'all got me I'll put the
clip up I said this is the most fun out
yo was pretty good right yes yeah yeah
it was really good it was good we're
gonna talk about it we're gonna talk
about so we got that and then um I do
want to give a shout out to an unrelated
game that um I just actually played uh
yesterday it's called fading afternoon
and it's about a small team I want to
shout out I believe it's called yo
um little pixel art game it's like
Yakuza River City Ranch remember River
City Ransom
Double Dragon
remember this game techno cop but for
back in the day for Genesis yeah we used
to murder people it's crazy it was bad
bloody and glory and it's like all those
games had a baby so basically
you this actually cool so you just got
you got you you was doing a bit you come
home right everything is River City ran
into the fix a lot you know what I'm
saying you go through but I'm going for
King whoever this guy this team is they
have the best animation I've ever seen
on pixel art
like to the point where you where you
put your jacket on smoke to sink throw
this throw the um things on it's called
fading afternoon it's right now only on
Steam we get a little rock Ally it's
coming to switch first I don't know if
any other console has it it's it's like
it has a date night cycle I get it it's
then the fighting is so amazing like
they got the block he he's basically
Steven Seagal you come at him he
disarmed you take the knife then the
bloodiness the the beheading you run
into the spots with the toes it is off
the chain the control's a little wonky I
ain't going for you I gotta get that
control together but once you master it
yeah fading afternoon y'all gotta try
this I hope it ain't on Unity because if
he blow up then he gonna have to owe
money
tonight later yeah we're gonna get to
that but bro I got it I gotta support
you it it's game is is hilarious So
based oh here's the 40 plus play King
You're gonna laugh so like I said you
come home from doing your bib your OG
meets you outside the jail right so he
like yo this what's going on you know
what I'm saying you gotta I'm gonna put
some numbers on your books after you
know because you just came home whatever
whatever and then he was like um you get
you get you get your profit he's like
dude you got to start hitting the
streets you got to find out what
happened to the old crew so some of the
old crews out the game other crew and
then you'll be seeing the gangs post up
on your block
post it up legit so you gotta walk
through them so you can eat the beef
or you can leave it alone now if you
beef that is on so it's on site in any
part of town you at where they at so it
is the funny yo D it is the funniest
most brutal bloody craziest game I've
ever played idiot it's like you gotta
support this Choice fading afternoon
gotta try it out so that's pretty much
been it so I'm attic you want to help
with the uh Super Chat sir yeah sure
shout out to
to YouTube for making the super
technology best that's best we got a
five dollar super jump Village style
killer uh starting off the PS data play
Baby Steps was a hell of a decision
should have led off with Final Fantasy
VII rebirth and ended with Spider-Man 2.
I actually I think they should have
flipped that they should have opened
with uh
Spiderman and ended with uh with Final
Fantasy because to me Final Fantasy was
the it was it was it was the show
yeah five dollar Super Chat from Gerald
Mack the new name for the toxic Fanboy
is anti-gamer no more credit for being a
fan of games clearly you hate games
hashtag anti-gamer salute the Lord
got a two dollar suit uh two two dollar
screenshots from Robert kellett one says
baby legs game of the year
baby legs
and then the other one says eight days
later I'm feeling great exercising I he
didn't put it but hashtag Health as well
oh it's a little slow uh then we got
Mexican zolberg upgraded to uh
membership Lord silver definitely put
those logos in the chat man welcome yeah
welcome him to the silver Club
got two more two dollar super chats from
Robert kellett uh one says joystick
won't be pleased don't worry just stick
your man coming and the Nexus says I
can't wait for preschool iron Lords okay
okay got a five dollar subtract from zip
Davis zip with the drip here Garfield is
so good big link is starting to sweat
and is looking as great as Optimus Prime
when he dies yo
yo that's wow that's wow I see you zip
with the drill dude that was the last
one
for real for real all hell the IOP
salute the Lord I got you if you got to
do something about it uh oh hey I am
solo the homie two dollars to chat have
a great show y'all salute to you Titans
salute brother see you out here killing
it with the interviews blessings
blessings shout out to my man scotsy uh
member for one month gotta use this to
send love to Lord Cog on behalf of all
us [__] fans so happy back up and
running the Undisputed host with them
all absolutely it's a blessing it's a
blessing to be here that for sure thank
you so much then we got my man
jfx88 five dollar Super Chat rumor is
the narring system shroud equal and star
yard station has a significantly better
bit of credits eyeball Emoji oh it is a
new hustle oh I gotta get over the
narian you know how dudes be dropping
their wallet
I
I enjoyed uh tears of the Kingdom a
little bit less when they uh when they
patch the Duke glitch because I was so
and I was enjoying what did they capture
they they patched the dupe glitch like
you couldn't duplicate stuff anymore and
the reason I I was a little uh annoyed
with it is because I like the building
aspect of Tears of the Kingdom I just
don't like the scavenger aspect of
getting the materials to build so and so
if I wanted to make a little something
something I just duped it like 25. yo
the Nintendo Nintendo's like we and I
ain't cool live I kind of dropped tears
of the Kingdom after they did that and
they just after the glitches going
because because it just made like
traveling such a pain like listen man I
guess seven man is out there he got he
got there he got the Darius system I'm
gonna go check it out she was gonna
shout out to the brother K is Santi five
dollars Super Chat salute to the Lords
on this fine Sunday don't sleep on party
and oh man oh yeah I was in the beta
this week
yeah there was a beta this weekend I've
totally forgot don't say no party
animals my kids and I jumped on it and
oh boy it's too much fun four guys it
had for all guys energy remember when we
saw a kid and we was like these little
adorable animals out here being real
rough and grabbing people up they
um someone said the the chest under
white room is still there that's what I
was saying like this this isn't new when
it comes to like these vendor cheeses
because they've been in a lot of
Bethesda games yeah yeah salute salute
it's pretty much what they do in order
for like the vendors to have an
inventory is they put a a chest that's
unreachable yes under the map and they
link it to that person so when you click
let me see you're aware is it pretty
much goes to that chest yeah well if you
can find bigger finances you know say
you know maybe having limited money
every day but if you go to certain
planets and then wait a couple hours you
come back you know but anyway
hold up hold up that's something that we
didn't really talk about what's up
during the Starfield things you know
that is crazy attention from people that
don't know if you sleep on you know a
planet that's that's just you know
farther away from the Sun you're going
to get less rotation because obviously
if the closer you are to the Sun the
faster you rotate around it like if you
so for instance like you go to the place
that we're talking about you have to
sleep for like 24 to 48 hours for a
whole rotation right if you travel to a
planet such as Venus in the middle of
the uh the middle of the Galaxy you
actually oh can do it in like 11 hours
because it's closer in the rotation so
if like you look at like the Sleep menu
and it shows the hours you'll notice
it's skipping three hours every time
because they're taking to account where
you are yes on the Galaxy yeah and what
game is doing that that's game of the
year
over your oldest gay still I can't wait
when we do the uh the Gable voice Jade
it's gonna be fun that's gonna be fun
that that's going to be really fun yeah
and I'm going to do the same thing we
did last year oh yeah we did
do you remember that joint from the
original NES called narc I believe that
was the first game I played at five
years old King remember that knock
okay well narc is is to give different
games yes it's an arc in the arcade
which is bloody that game is crazy
bloody it was like more I think Midway
made Mark and then is the one that came
home to the Nintendo
and that was kind of decent um yeah
shout out to knock you shoot them in the
kilos fall on the floor
absolutely not you already know and I
think that's we got on the super chats I
do want to get a patreon question that
we missed last week shout out to
Benjamin what's your last name amaru
reposting since this question was missed
last week no worries I'm sorry let me
explain the reason stuff was missed last
week is because we just got back from
past West yes it was just there was so
much stuff going on and you know it
completely because normally what I do at
the end of every month the last podcast
before the the previous month is I will
update for the next month so like when
you guys see like those posts I schedule
all those I spend like an hour and a
half every month doing that and I just
we would at that time because when we
went to Pax police at the end of the
month I forgot to put those posts hold
me down
I forgot to put that in for the for the
following month uh I apologize for that
normally I'm a lot better on that I I
have it on my my tablet to update me
when I got to do stuff because I'm
getting old but so uh you know we we
will get that and you know I definitely
apologize for that we'll go ahead and
read that now I'm bringing up the uh the
patreon currently man it's it's a big
question okay welcome back to the
regular scheduled programming slot Lords
I look forward to you having a blessed
day with the family and friends in the
spirit of football oh man we're going to
talk about football
being once again upon us I would love to
hear if any of you have a favorite
moment from this wonderful game of
violent chess mine would have to be
Super Bowl 2008 my charges missed the S8
by one against the I don't know what uh
he always joked let me Zoom this in okay
he always joked that the year the
charges won it all he'll die but uh but
a happy man fader would seem not far off
that was our last game together man
sorry about your loss man oh as he died
a few months later I know I I felt the
the New York Giants never uh were on a
magical run so I put a big bet on them
huge underdogs while in Vegas I got so
much crap for taking them you don't want
to witness history what's the matter
with you the paths are going undefeated
when the game was over I smiled all the
way to the bank but before I secured the
bag I responded to the haters and said I
did witness history Brothers
I've never won back uh backed up brother
so never went back to back Super Bowls
18 to one you guys were just rooting for
the wrong historical moment gotcha
looking forward to your own great
sports moment or a football moment I
guess football because he wears Super
Bowl with it and he wanted football my
um
it has to be Keyshawn Johnson when he
went to the Buccaneers and they got that
Super Bowl got that ring was that that
was the year that Janet Jackson showed
me
[Laughter]
the Val [__] it may have it may have
been demand I think I think that was the
year because uh because uh Rick he's at
Rick house God bless her so
um
all right everybody got a I'm a Jets fan
through and through but the reason why
I'm a Jet fan is because of Keyshawn
Johnson so
Keyshawn Johnson I felt that the judge
did him dirty and he went to the
Buccaneers and he goes to the Buccaneers
and I said I'm gonna ride with him until
his career is over and he got his ring
over there
and that had to be the most gratifying I
remember I said if he make it to the
Super Bowl I'm gonna go buy one of those
300 rails oh I forgot about that yeah
remember when we got into the beef at
the stadium oh yeah
those are old Lord stories
if they poured beans on my car at the
tailgate and then weeks showing back up
they're like oh my God let me clean that
off there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what
was going on yeah yeah it was about to
be a stadium brawl and kicks was lit I
actually do have a favorite moment
it was the um
that Super Bowl the Seattle I don't know
what their name is Seahawks had that
Super Bowl in the in the bag and they
screwed up on the two-point card oh boy
Russell Wilson through the interception
and it was about to be oh
when they were supposed to let Marshawn
Lynch run it in
remember Richard Sherman face
[Music]
that's so disgusting yeah classic all
right Buzz is as a 90s fan remember
every year in the 90s you had to go
through the Cowboys in the NFC
championship
and I could not stand Jimmy Johnson you
know I got them Cowboys heavy the other
one on the way that came after Barry
Switzer and we gonna beat the boy and
they would smoke us right and this was
during this that Joe Montana had left
and this was the Steve Young era and and
all announcement here in Montana he
can't win a ring he tracked he always
lose today like if you lose to the
Cowboys they done with you so it was
kind of like the Jessie out when they
lose to the pictures you know what I'm
saying like it's that rivalry yeah we
got one game off of them now I will
never forget oh you can't wait can't
wait brother can't wait
dude I was lit so anyway I never forget
it was one year it was I think it's 94.
and I was looking at sports center and
it was like breaking news the 49ers have
signed Dion said and I was like what
yeah that's my favorite Corner that's my
favorite position he was doing you know
what I'm saying oh and they had those
red and white all those those they had
these crispy you uniforms that year that
you could only get man that team ran
rough shot I love Leon match up with a
young Randy Moss oh yeah yeah that was
crazy that was great so salute to them
they destroyed the Cowboys and they went
to the Super Bowl destroyed the charger
sorry Benjamin and um that's what Steve
he's like I could take the monkey off my
back you run the Super Bowl he had like
five touchdowns in the first oh that was
crazy anyway that's that's me that's my
story and that is the uh patreon
question and we all caught up in the
other super chances now I didn't see any
yeah
okay yeah so um
we're married
yeah Okay no Okay okay we get the case
yeah okay we got easy five dollars uh
two dollars from Doctor Stranger call
I'll show you how much a party you had
and why yeah
yo bro back to you hey
where the hell is where the hell it's
off
all right so we look like we are good
dude Dr Jay love y'all behave yourself
sir and uh we're gonna get into it last
week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the recent success of soft Schofield
which aspect do you consider the most
impressive the winner of the latest ILP
poll with 35 percent of the vote was the
messy Lords I don't care y'all better
put respect on God Howard's name coming
in at second place with a razor close 34
of the vote was 1 million plus on Steam
one million plus Xbox early on Xbox
Early Access Premium Edition sales in
third place at 24 of the vote was the
biggest but that's the game launch ever
at Six Million players group and then
last place with only six percent of the
vote was the current number two most
played game on Xbox Live between
fortnite and Call of Duty shout out to
everybody who's Rock the vote Lord King
man what's your thoughts people who are
feeling that the most impressive thing
about Starfield launch was y'all better
put respect on God's name that one
you gotta You Gotta Be You Gotta put
respect his name he's the Michael Jordan
that is like he
had championships and never lost like
that's that's his joint this star field
is going to go to beat game of the year
like he he's six for six like that's
don't put that 76 under him that's not
him bro don't do that don't do that
don't put don't worry yeah but
um I will say this King if that and that
if that one game of the year
social media will be interesting I will
say I might tune in that day messy [__]
might just tune in to see things because
that would be very interesting but it is
it is a competitive yeah I agree with
addict on you know Sports Gators up in
there you got so many games in there but
it's gonna be I'll be tuning into this
this game was for sure so he got that so
we are all good we're gonna set it off
my topic kind of like a combo topic so
um obviously the first part of it will
be Mortal Kombat and uh Mortal Kombat 1
is out right now now officially but I
know King I know okay and that
officially out for King yet when the
iron bank gets here so we'll Rectify
that situation
so we got that but um yeah Early Access
guys they and Lords yeah you got it you
know what I mean so um
yeah I just wanted to talk about it
really quickly
um so I got another apology to make okay
so remember how I had said
that when turkey ain't
is out you know it blow away every game
fighting game graphically it's not even
close everybody just bending knees so um
now that I got Mortal Kombat in the crib
um all right so technically still the
chair but but but the Gap ain't as big
as I that's why it is
listen and especially and especially
with all the stuff that they got going
on in this storytelling World facts and
the level of photorealism the facial
animation the movie style production
is staggering it really is staggering
the transitions from you know the live
act whatever the Cinematic in real time
to the fighting in real time is all
perfect
what's good brother
how you doing man why do I feel like I'm
being talked about her yeah bro
we've been because what have I done now
he's not happy with you right now
I know I know why I know why I know why
we are the votal combat topic and he
yeah he ain't he's not happy with the
bank but uh yeah let's let's introduce
the uh there was only enough you know to
to pay for one a hundred twenty dollars
I was like what the hell is this you
know it's funny I was talking to to
solve last night I was like yeah he uh
kick cogs real big on me playing this he
said I can't run for this oh yeah I was
getting mad I was like bro we not doing
this well you ain't playing the biggest
fighting game of the year I was like I
was like I was like solve just tell Carl
we can't do it
so I was like but addict I'd be lying
what
my apologies King I I get you listen I'm
shaking my head I'm listening today
we're gonna get to it but first we get
my brothers
all I know is I got somebody Street
Fighter I ain't seen nobody out in the
streets
I don't never see you on cause you're
invisible all the time
and of course we have arriving from an
undisclosed location uh most technical
gaming Lord the solo game of this with a
single player selfish experience and
also the softer Davis the Lord of
clarity and Lord angrily patreon of the
big iron bank right now
PC Master races oh Lord sorry my brother
it is so good to see you how you doing
sir I'm uh I'm kind of yeah what's going
on since yesterday just a little bit
under the weather I I sound a little bit
nasal the chest is a little bit you know
what like when you cough and you feel
like it needles in your chest oh no it's
been coughing like that yeah a little
boogery a little bit like I felt a
little fever just a little while ago oh
bro you know I've been doing better
goals yeah yeah
so I mean it feels like it's just a cold
but if it progresses I will definitely
at least
um Christ took a uh a covet test and I
was like look I was like if you get
worse you still gotta go because this
new this new strain don't care about it
and it's not a lot of the nutrients
progressing worse she just has a call
yeah Jess just went through it and him
been talking and it's not showing up
sometimes on the on the home test just
just for the record so if you want to be
on go to the clinic go to the clinic get
the PCR or the rapid and they have to
attack me I told you that day I had uh
orange juice lemon ginger turmeric um
to add to your um defense on my I call
it the health armor they said um vitamin
D3
vitamin C and zinc
you know for those who want to do some
natural you know defense mechanisms
y'all want to get to get on that but
continue drink some of that soursop too
yeah yeah facts can't put me on to that
I was like wait a minute yeah he put me
on to that and it really it helped when
it right at the beginning of covid when
I there was no I couldn't tell if I had
it or not but I didn't have any symptoms
other than I had difficulty breathing
and in the middle of the night it was
like three in the morning the king came
to me with a bottle of soursop and
something else it was some other thing
these two things and you good yeah
and and it really worked so that I did
that and again the the tea with ginger
yes and lemon and turmeric like that
that shot helps a lot too
um so I feel again it a little little
boogery hopefully it's just the cold
weather
I don't like that kind of taste
and that um so yeah yeah and then it's
funny because I had to get up today to
go to a doctor's appointment with wifey
all the way down in Brooklyn
I was like I open on Sunday they were
like yes yeah we're open on Sundays
that's all good we saw that um
yeah what have I been playing I've been
trying to play the crew motor Fest on
the Rock Ally and it has not been
cooperating good save your crew throw I
want to do it all of us on this because
right now we were I was in the middle of
the Mortal Kombat okay okay so um what I
was gonna say say that for after the
because we're gonna all talk we waited
for you we want to talk about the crew
together okay yeah I wish I could have
played more but uh let's just say I had
a little bit of technical difficulty
last night was a piece of Hardware oh
yeah sure
and it's a me problem because it's me
being like I can make this better oh no
you know what's funny like Saul calls me
and he's like did you does this stuff do
that and I've looked like no mine does
not say that he's like damn
I was like I was like what did you do
nothing nothing
I'll fix it don't worry about it so I I
finally got it fixed and things are
beautiful but uh that kind of impeded my
gaming time for uh for that the crew and
what we're what we're talking it's NDA
you gotta wait till Monday what's funny
is
um I got shut down mine was supposed to
be in the situation downstairs and she
was like no word no
Take that upstairs to your other room
nope word okay for that no um you
already all over the place
so I did I did what I said I was gonna
do and initially I thought I was like
that's the same organ and it's because
again I I didn't do something that I was
supposed to do I forgot about that it's
funny how we all speak it in codes
tomorrow guys tomorrow y'all gotta
understand what this conversation's
gonna make boy says
but yeah um yeah that was it that was it
what else did I played I play anything
else during the week um didn't play
Mortal Kombat I was not planning I I
didn't really guys to be I was not
planning you guys to be so excited for
Mortal Kombat I didn't finish I didn't
finish the 11th story oh bro you didn't
do the aftermath deals I didn't do it I
didn't finish
off you can watch the videos
just watch the video at this point yeah
if you want to play Mortal Kombat one
all you gotta do is no you got stop it
foolishness
anyways that's what it said that's been
it that's been all right so please be
here yes that was good to have you good
to have you so pretty much where I was
at they're going super chats yes so um
basically what I was saying because
we're in the middle of the MK One topic
and the unique topic so I'll start with
MK1 so pretty much I would say how I owe
um uh Ed Boon an apology
because I was popping off that Tekken is
just Leaps and Bounds beyond anything
anybody else is doing in the fighting
game graphically with ue5 and Mortal
Kombat had to let me know that bro you
need to relax because what we doing is
the not only is it amazing we got the
facial animation we got the the the
movie style production we got the
transition from the you know I'm saying
from the real time to the thing and and
guess what the gapping is as big as you
thought be
and I was looking I was like oh
this is so it I thought it was head like
like this like this joint is yeah like
and then where they got attacking they
backgrounds and everything going on in
their stages
oh boy so yeah just tell a story the
stage is crazy so salute to them
um I will say it's not even close
anymore
as far as narrative and fighting games
addict we were just talking about it
it's not even like it's to the point
where I'm like everybody else just bend
the knee and do what they doing right
because it's it's literally yeah shout
out they got the JC video yeah so um
it's literally like not only do they
evolve the entire roster not only is
everything a movie style production it
is
like high quality they could literally
take what's going on on screen replace
it and like live action and make a movie
this is a movie this is a movie movie
like the stuff was going on obviously
you know I don't know how much I don't
want to spoil for y'all because I know
y'all didn't really be playing the last
one the story was but on act three
um I mean yeah my part of the story was
non-existent because
he's talking about 11 11 right but all I
will say is this part you will know as
soon as you boot up is you know uh fire
god Liu King is now beholden to the
timeline and he has reset things in a
way you know in His image and it's
basically give people the opportunity
you don't have to go the path that you
went in your previous timeline right so
this is opened up new possibilities for
everyone so it's almost like everybody
has a new origin story and it is so well
done some you gonna be like yo that's
crazy right between certain factions and
certain things then there's others well
you could be like damn like what
happened this side like you don't say so
it's it's it's it's it's so well done so
again many old fragrance you got I'm not
gonna you know surprise I will say you
know my man I can just talk about my man
because you know I'm Kung Lao with the
joint this is you know Ridge
now the original one from the one that
had died that had beat Goro who used to
be Earth Champion right not the new
younger one that's Goofy and always too
impatient and foolish this is OG right
so we got that um they I gotta talk
about the um the Cameo mechanic so base
pretty much how you start the fight you
know you pick your character and then
they got a whole separate roster of
characters called The Cameo Fighters and
numb dudes is like your tag in partner
like they come in they harass yeah but
it's like the only thing King is is
getting me mad is that
it's to the point night like bro y'all
teasing y'all could do this for a player
come on right like y'all teasing now
because I like I ain't going for Kano is
one of the hottest tag Partners like
because he sometimes I mean I bring some
long rings so you gotta look out for
that then like let's just say you know
how these dudes I'm gonna call out your
brother Kyle your brother you know how
like Kyle he find a combo and then it's
like bad bad juggle bad bad you sitting
there watching your energy with the
Cameo dude you hold I think it's back
and forth in the Cameo button you can
break anybody's combo if they if they're
Cameo like they have a me they have like
a circle how many times you can keep
bringing them in bringing them in and
then it replenishes over the course of
the match so if somebody's just choosing
you or doing too much of that boom stop
that he come out break up the combo do
some stuff
yeah yeah so the camera Fighters or the
camera Fighters actual fighters in the
game now some are because I I said Kano
I'm assuming candles in the game
illustrate kano's not playable you be
Kano by himself that's the controversy
there are some Cameo Fighters at least
that I've not beat the game maybe addict
is farther than me but there are some
Cameo fights I saw I haven't played this
game now so oh okay well I saw that they
had like old school MK1 scorpion okay
MK1 Sub-Zero so you know they are in the
game but they're also Cameo fight but
there are a group of Cameo Fighters that
you cannot play
outside of them being a cameo fighter do
you think they should have did like a
like an option at the bottom right that
you click and it's like do you want to
play as one of the cameos I I thought so
yeah it's like I I think they try to do
that to some realm of like okay this
kind of breaks the immersion of the
story but if you put them like in the
far off like none of this is real right
like it's not exact it's not that's the
part where it breaks the immersion King
because
remember Striker from MK3 the cop yeah
he's one of a cameo fight you can't pick
him and again he has nothing to do with
the storyline so that's the only part
that breaks the realism of some of the
narrative because you play the story
like he ain't even in there you know
what I'm saying so that part is a little
I'm in the middle with it because the
the idea of it is fire but the narrative
part will get you off so you got that
and I'm at the point now I'm like bro I
want a four-player Tekken Tag Mortal
Kombat y'all teasing like this y'all
could do it like I know y'all could do
it I always say the fatalities are more
Savage than ever it is I haven't done
one yeah they got they got the easy
joint too I'm gonna show you how to do
that joint too they got that and like um
also I went into this literally the
definition of blind so oh do all what
you do before you do the story go to the
tutorial you get a whole Channel okay
cool you get a little hole okay he's
talking about I don't know I I thought
maybe you know when the the finish it
comes up like right except it'll pop up
like these or no no they just want you
to know them yeah yeah because what it
is in in story mode there's really the
option to really do a lot of fatalities
is not there because they're doing other
stuff the Cinematic stuff the last thing
I want to say about the Cameo Fighters
is they have remember like the X-ray
moves off where you just press the
buttons
yeah the Dual joint I like the what's
interesting is like the Scorpion and
Sub-Zero one because like like it is
truly kid and play kick like they come
out they do stuff together they both
cinematic style man I'm suffering from
so much I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
look
um it's pretty good Ed bull I'm sorry
Edward I'm so sorry I was very
disrespectful I didn't have no fear in
the Mortal Kombat one at all I mean
after I saw it I mean I guess it looked
compared to the same spider
it looked like it looked like MK 11
right right it didn't really look like
you I guess you really got to get it in
the house to really shoot conferences yo
what's up what I'm gonna put this in the
chat okay King like this is the uh the
switch version
they've messed up like the side to side
thing wait what you're going left to
right they're going diagonal
they got their foot to switch business
oh
yo what's up with the diagonal
what's happening yeah
yeah they out here dragging it oh wow
that's crazy you know it's scaled down
you know hey remember they said the
memory of the issues can't play the
series
wow hey they brought that J all the way
down to the Tegra so I want to hear
about those Generations getting held
back they brought ue5 down to the Tegra
uh that's it that's it don't look good
hey Nintendo watch that drink or
something I'll tell you right now but
anyway so you got that and then yeah so
that's pretty much it you know I didn't
know if you guys obviously can't
definitely going to be picking it out
and uh I was just curious because your
father than me so what was your
experience how are you feeling about it
I I actually enjoy it um
I'm like I'm I'm button mashing man I
don't know what the hell I'm doing I
love it I love it like I I find like one
good move and then when they die when
they block it I just redo it I'm like
there's eventually yeah
you're not gonna block and I'm gonna hit
you and then when I feel like the
computers like this dude's using one boo
then they switch it up I'm like can imma
use her other moves that's all you got
to do so who have you been meaning uh
well it's stories
but I really like the sword dude you
like kenshi yeah can she I was gonna say
something about like the story what I've
noticed and I won't spoil anything but
I've noticed even Luke Kane's little
witchcraft thing where he re-did
everything it does feel like there's
like a butterfly effect where people are
still going back to how they work
yeah you shout out somebody in the chat
is saying that the Cameo Fighters are
explained narratively as you go on
I'm not far I'm early so whoever if that
person
finished it salute you'll probably get
plucked out of time or something like
that one thing that I will say
from Mortal Kombat is when I'm playing
it I feel like I'm playing like
like a super massive game or like a like
a Telltale Game like a very high uh
budgeted Telltale Game because it's like
like the game plays there but I feel
like Mortal Kombat is like look we're
gonna let you fight we want to tell a
story more than we care about you
fighting facts facts and it's a story
you care about like it's so good that
you care about it like you don't care
about the street fighter story it's
still ridiculous the Tekken story is
probably gonna be super ridiculous again
you know so if this is the only one you
really really care about and the way and
they've leaned into that in a way like
ever ever since they're the kind of the
reboot with MKX or whatever they really
the state up that storytelling crazy
it's not even close no I don't think
they're literally the best story in fact
like I don't even think nobody is on
that level it used to be checking was
hanging with them yeah yeah and then
they just they just went off yeah
because attacking was that it was the
production value of it right and the
whole you know you you knew you always
had your your cinematic at the
and these guys just took it to the next
level like nah we're gonna tell a real
story and I I think what it is solved
not to cut you also the WB effect and in
conjunction they got the movie license
was it Terminator
after seeing the last Mortal Kombat
movie though man let let nether realm
make the damn word
you like that one Kane
I think the animations are better than
the movies
and that's written by the majority of
the same people that are involved with
the projects I personally feel like a
lot of Mortal Kombat people
they don't want different though like
they they want a well-toed story with
their favorite characters yeah and I
felt like that movie just didn't do that
for me yeah I think that the focus on
that other dude yeah that doesn't feel
like he like if they had put him in this
game as you know he's Cannon now okay
you you build an interest like you build
up to it you create interest for the guy
but he was just kind of like a side
character it's like he was shoehorned
into it exactly surrounded by these
characters that you love yeah as opposed
to hey one of these characters is going
to be the main character I understand
don't do the Liu Kang thing again right
but
um not to mention usually when people do
stuff like that in form of TV
entertainment or movie entertainment
there's some form of like a past the
torch kind of thing going on and it
didn't feel like that it just felt like
you got the rage there you go with the
King's Point I will say that the
fighting I thought was you know for the
most decent I thought Sub-Zero were
gonna be like super shy in that one
remember like
you know
one thing I will say is like regardless
of Mortal Kombat one
I I played more combats in the past but
it's been like I've been the person in
the background I play like occasional
match or two yeah I remember like seeing
my friend Ronnie and uh and Tyler fight
that the last boss from like it was nine
or ten it was like in the giant Coliseum
and he was like destroying all like them
multiple times over and over again uh
like I've never really played a whole
Mortal Kombat thing I got it downloaded
it like one in the morning and Grace is
like oh it's time for bed no it's more
combat
I got it
he ripped off his shirt the Cat come
running
[Applause]
so I'm playing it like I looked at the
clock it's like three o'clock in the
morning yeah I was like man I played
this for three hours like it's okay it's
good
and then Grace gets up for water or
something and she comes out and she's
like you're still on the game I'm like
yeah I looked at it just like this it's
Mortal Kombat
don't mess up your relationship bro
so then I go to bed at like four in the
morning and I woke up you did the creek
back in the bed no at that time she knew
that night was a rat so I get I get I
get up
and then she's leaving to go to her
in-laws and she's like well what are you
doing I'm like it's podcasting more
stuff
I got up got something to eat and played
Mortal Kombat like if you noticed before
the podcast talked my camera is off yeah
I would be funny what if when she asked
him if he do the yell from the original
movie
would come on
it's my my brother and his girlfriend
are like play fighting yesterday it was
like it was like 12 30 1 o'clock in the
morning and then and then I just
randomly say finish him
yo y'all messy but not salute on that
and then obviously King will be taken
care of on that but I know I know y'all
gonna pick it up Plano song I'm assuming
my people in the chat uh what's up my my
girlfriend uh she she has an ex-husband
family oh just to clarify
yo
[Laughter]
now yo remember when M bison was the
hardest boss at the end yes and then
Mortal Kombat said hold my beer when you
got Goro oh girl and he would jump that
glitch that stood up he could just jump
on you and then oh he'll grab you by
your ribs
then they got him they upped the entry
with MK remember with Shao Khan and
debut and what made it bad was Shao God
is that he used to talk so
yeah
so disrespectful everybody remember you
know who used to whip us badly
The Unsung
we will never forget him because I think
he whipped us for five hours straight
straight
we didn't even know his day we just gave
him a name his name is like rydu or
Roger yeah
what that reminds me of my friend Tyler
played was like one of the earlier uh
WWE games and this dude dressed up as uh
Leonidas from 300. lead him around the
map and like he couldn't do that at that
point the dude was doing his special
over and over again and he had that met
the helmet was going back yeah
those are the bosses man but yeah go
check out that MK1 I was gonna
transition to the unity let's check out
more Mortal Kombat to talk about
because this is a two-part topic I
didn't know it was gonna go this long
but um look we got to talk about it um
this is the uh the hottest thing in
gaming right now uh yeah unity's new uh
pricing model uh shaking the developer
Community
um now starting to get death threats so
um yeah pretty pretty much um there's
been an open letter as far as developers
fighting back against uh this new price
Model
um allegedly there was supposed to be
um according to Bloomberg Unity CEO John
riccatello was set to address employees
Thursday morning but the company in my
meeting was canceled and two of unity
offices were closed because of alleged
death threats it is that real y'all so
just for the recap for those who don't
know shout out to The Verge
um early this week Unity makers of a
video game engine announced that mostly
used by Popular by Indie developers
announced he was making change into its
pricing model in addition to charging
yearly subscription fees Unity is
planning to implement a pay per install
pricing scheme
charging developers each time a game is
installed on the device once that game
has met specific download and revenue
thresholds this news was met with
sizable backlash Indie developers
protested in drove some say they were
going to de-list their game
um others were saying that they already
had small profit margins and this was
damaging their trust because there was
no Clarity no warning
um some have threatened to not use uh
Unity again and encouraging players to
pay but not download their games to to
avoid incurring new fees so um that John
mccatello CEO he's been the force of
controversy because as the person who's
driving
um this model at um Unity he was
formerly the CEO of Electronic Arts when
either controversial loot
boxing was added to FIFA he made news
when he called developers effing idiots
over the fact that developers were
reluctant to introduce monetization to
their um to their development basically
he was saying like yeah you're an idiot
if you don't use blue Box's monetization
in your games free money you better get
out the public there's also a clip of
racquetello um talking during a
shareholder call about charging
Battlefield players a dollar just to
reload their guns in the game
it'd be funny to see just one live
stream like that it's like shoot I'm
shooting my shooter
I said hold on hold on I think my food
stamp card worked
that was about to the EBT
I gotta eat
you can buy two noodles
that's why the unity CEO this is the
last one you spend your whole pay check
in one bag one battle there that's crazy
in one match you win for real the fact
that that was being discussed is
interesting
um and final thinking you'll find this
interesting the unity CEO also raised
eyebrows this week when it was reported
that he sold Off 2 000 Unity shares
right before the company announced this
news with the stock price
and right and right before he did that
he just got off the phone with Eugene
like yo
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so yeah it's been crazy we've seen all
types of developers come out and fight I
believe Cult of the Lamb said as of
January 1st they gonna delist their game
because of that it's just crazy so what
do we think y'all you know about this
controversy you know what's your
thoughts you think it lasts do you think
they fold do you think Jon stays on a
square and no rolling oh there's one
other detail too because
um a lot of there's still a lot of
questions and people were like well you
know what about if I'm on Game Pass
PlayStation Plus and the statement was
oh don't worry this don't affect y'all
we're gonna charge Microsoft Sony fan
they're gonna take care of that and I
don't know if that was ever discussed
with the Publishers attic what do you
think about all this stuff that's going
on man let's start with you and look it
it if they feel strong about these weird
policies that doesn't seem like it was
really thought of uh then receive the
consequences we got to get Unity up out
of here uh it's just like to me
you know be transparent while you're
making these decisions if the company's
financially not doing well then have a a
back and forth with you know some
communication it's just I think
I don't know if this is a the company
won't survive in five years kind of
energy or we are upset because of Game
Pass backs because of PlayStation Now
bags because of all this money that's
being floated around because of uh you
know free to play
why am I not getting a piece of that to
me what's interesting if it was just
about financially being better off in
the future you would just say yo if your
game hits a certain threshold you owe us
a chat right uh but it's not about that
because they use the words like
downloads and stuff I think this is
about
coach the lamb
cashed out and sold their game to to
games uh to uh Game Pass and we can get
a paycheck I don't like that so then
it's just like okay
that install is what makes it really
weird that the choice of words because
that means you know uh we we can't
guarantee that this game will be played
on Game Pass but if it's downloaded we
get a piece and it's just like dude I'm
sure if you went to some of these
companies it's like look
if you want to work with it that's fine
we'll give you the backing we'll give
you the tools we'll help you develop
stuff on the back end for your game but
if you take a Game Pass back we want a
percentage
um
I'm pretty sure people would be more
open to that than like this weird you
could take this and see you know how I
know when when a policy can be took
multiple ways you got an issue
if you can literally take it's like that
thing that says
um where they say two two words and
people hear two different words right
it's like that's what I'm getting here
like when it comes to a policy that
revolves around people's livelihood
there shouldn't be room for
misinterpretation right it should be
Clarity that's the issue the issue is
that it feels like they went out here
what makes me think that a couple like
to me the reason this was rushed because
it does feel rushed is it feels like
they know a big unity game is about to
go on Game Pass or something and they're
trying to get it before that happens
yeah well Dev came off got the studio
something crab something and they put
out an announcement like yo because I
guess they had to reveal like yo we got
a game coming out next year that's going
to be on Game Pass like how does this
affect us and it was kind of like um
they asked you know Unity you know like
how are you even counting these these
downloads because what if one person you
know it's like hey I downloaded on my XS
PC like is that three like and basically
their response was our proprietary
system we'll figure that out and it was
kind of like very trust me bro energy
trust me yeah hey without giving a lot
of sister to addict's point devs are
asking a lot of very specific questions
and they don't feel like they're getting
Clarity and also the attic's point is
that a lot of people are upset because
one terms of service right is this a
violation and then the retroactive
nature so you've already put a game now
you think you Caked Up King but now you
could have a bill from the unity IRS
they can come in talking about yo you
owe from these downloads so there's
uncertainty about how much you owe if
your game popped off that's why part of
me feels like there's more going on here
because it's like if you want to like
close the Lambs or Among Us I was like
yo huge we we've been seeing you get you
you be eaten we would like a percentage
of x amount of something they will look
at that but like I'd rather give you
this percentage than change engines so
okay take that money that's cool leave
me alone but it seems like they're
sitting there they want to be a
publisher but not a publisher they want
a percentage of everyone's of everyone's
pie but they don't really want to offer
anything besides the engine
it's like look the engine's good but
people are paying you you you came up
with terms at the beginning you need to
honor those terms now if you want to do
if you want to this is the definition of
how to ruin a company overnight
because uh let's be real here Unreal
Engine uh there being more and more
transparent they're being more and more
user-friendly don't play around Unity
you could get replaced real quick I mean
you know epic is looking right right we
know they they didn't think shout out to
my man Lucius Augustus to make it a good
point too I was gonna get to it it was
my turn he was like don't forget y'all
this is also all about mobile and
getting this mobile bag too but I don't
know
the free-to-play stuff yeah so it's just
like look Unity wants that money so bad
you know I I'm I'm curious if they're on
this mindset where we'll have people
leave but people that have no other
options yeah we'll make that money off
of them and if that's the issue man
shame on you because it's like taking
advantage of of people at a time like
especially the kind of world we live in
right now the gaming industry is only
shrinking inside getting bigger yeah and
it's like validating yeah
well it's not even just consolidating
you know we we got we got companies
shutting down I mean look what happens
to embrace your group they it seems like
they they're like a broken ship losing
sectors of the ship every five seconds
now we're just gonna get past this uh
this uh court stuff and then we just
gotta get back we being like
you know thanks for holding us down we
got you when we finish bro
we're gonna double back
that's all I got to say on the subject
no doubt stop so what you think man you
win it why
not Unity
um for me man obviously this is
egregious but I think it's it's
heartbreaking because I tell you this
like when we go to a Pax right and we
walk the show floor right
we hear three names facts here we hear
game maker we hear unreal and we hear
unity and what because what's the first
question usually we asked right yeah
to try to play the middle ground a
little bit do you think that Unity is
entitled to any Financial backing once a
game has surpassed people's like
original exponents no not at all this
retroactive stuff that is that I think
that's one of the more egregious things
to me if they look if they were charging
you this if they were charging this tax
per purchase right it's slimy as hell
it's a way grind me
I wouldn't have an issue with it if they
were charging you this tax upfront per
purchase hey one per your purchase you
get this little extra tax on top of the
install thing is it's very scary
terminology it's super it's super scary
terminology because it doesn't matter
now you're what you're telling me is
that if I have if if I have uh which if
I own the game and that and download it
on multiple multiple devices
it is now going you're going to charge
for each install you're going to try to
if I own the game and I download it on
uh one my laptop then I downloaded on my
desktop then I let download it on the
Rock you're gonna charge me for three
installs that that's that's where that
that's where that uh in between
languages
algorithm no algorithm it's not gonna
figure anything out it's gonna charge
you three years trust me bro our
proprietary system will able to
determine this is
and the crazy thing let's say you don't
have all of those different devices
right how often do you go in and be like
hey you know what I'm not playing this
I'm gonna uninstall it and then I'll
I'll get back to Bam install it again
there's certain games I've uninstalled
and reinstalled multiple times for
whatever reason because I have the
storage
algorithm to get you to pay yeah
this is one of my favorite words this is
as egregious as it gets it is so there
you can't look at it any other way other
than being money hungry and greedy
there's no way to look at it and the
fact that you do it environment
um in the fact that they blindsided so
many devs with it
crazy I'm just like
and then you know what it is like
there's they there's no way to paint
this in a better light they had such a
bad week that they there was nothing to
do but be as honest about what they were
doing as possible quote unquote there's
no way to paint this there's no way to
go get around it this is what it is and
it's egregious any which way you look at
it so I it just feels like they're
purposely trying to tank the company so
you gotta hit a statement though today
all right so they said they announced
the model this is this is a price
increase it will only affect a small
subset of current Unity editors they
said developers who will be impacted are
generally those who have successful kids
and uh generating Revenue way above the
thresholds we outlined in our foreign
don't worry about this unless you are
successful yeah if you get hot right now
yo I
need but our goal is go with the money
you make you make all right so check it
out it gets better this means that
developers who are still building their
business and growing the audience of
their games will not pay a fee the
program is designed yet the program was
designed specifically this way to ensure
developers can find success before the
install Field tick takes effect we want
to be clear that the counter for Unity
runtime fee install starts on January
1st it they said now they're saying it
is not retroactive or Perpetual we will
charge once for a news on install not an
ongoing Perpetual license royalty like
Revenue share so yeah they're trying to
act like this is a great thing and so
why don't you just charge it up front
for the purchase right do the right
thing if you're gonna charge the tax be
like yo every purchase why don't they
not charge nothing at all well that's
true and just let it be purchase the
engine you did what you did God bless
good luck like you know we we powered
your system good luck what's up so so a
Dev one so this is funny somebody clap
what is this clap back what will this
Price ever increase can we get it locked
in a contract in writing how are you
tracking installs on PCS how do you
differentiate between demos and full
games do uninstalls and reinstalls count
how do you count all this dude what's
going in how you count offline installs
how do you get like he's got all the
offline will there be additional taxes
how will you track people on Steve so
he's going in he's got all
hi Gary
um this is Unity response a lot of
questions here and we'll do our best to
get each answer but first we want to say
we heard your
concerned Community loud and clear on an
annual basis we'll evaluate and adjust
pricing models across our product
portfolio we have a proprietary data
bottle that calculates the number of
times the runtime is distributed for a
giving project we're happy to work with
any developer who's been victim of
piracy so that they are not unfairly
hurt by unwanted installs so basically
you still don't have a plan for
everything still heard trust me
I got you bro he is he is baby it just
works he's baby Bobby kodeg that's who
he baby Bobby Cody that's what it is
like he's I'm telling you he'd come from
the Bobby tree yeah he does he's got
from that club
is outside bro you know you know he and
he got he got uh he he got accused of
like sexual harassment and oh oh man he
really on that Bobby Vine I didn't know
that yeah he got by it was a it's like
fast forward so he was like what is like
how can I get out of this let's let's
take the company so I could save my word
look Godzilla
[Laughter]
man this is so bad like you it looks
like you're trying to Crater the company
for no reason I don't know if this is
like because one one thing I did notice
at Pax right the small games are going
to use game makers right the pixel games
right but more and more more and more
people like you you we it's so easy you
eat it's so easy oh this our little
five-man team yeah we're moving our game
from four to five bro remember when we
played
um was it down by the blade the machine
yep and we that was their first Jordan
small team and they was it was um what
you call it unreal yeah the the pizza
Bandit Pizza band it's only like a five
okay
oh
my little jealousy with that yeah like I
was I was busy interviewing the oven
worry about y'all interviews
they they pulled us it's good you know
be cool if we had a shirt to give them
when they gave us a shirt it'd be like
a shirt like oh
[Laughter]
only a few guys working on that and that
game looks ridiculous and they're like
yeah um so yeah we've been working on it
for like four or five months and then uh
a few months down the line we're gonna
move over to on row five and the game
should be out within the next year and
it's a few of them like it's it's insane
um so again if
if
ue5 development is has become that sort
of easy especially if you have
experience with ub4 already and it's
that much it's that much more versatile
you couple all of that with unity being
Unity right now it's kind of a it's kind
of a non-starter you really just it's a
no-brainer to go to UEFA so
I don't know bro I it just feels like
they're trying to create other company
for no reason I've never seen somebody
really trying to end their career now
what I was gonna say so and I've had
this conversation with addict it you
know I gotta try to be balanced with it
a little bit even though I do not like
this but do you think it's to the point
where like they just looked at the
numbers long term and it's like we just
can't survive unless we get this cut
maybe eue is just getting too popular
maybe like we said we're seeing more
devs utilizing a little bit more and you
know they're just saying we got to do
something otherwise long-term we might
not be in the game you think maybe that
has any Factor
I mean it could be absolutely again they
have to be looking at the market right
they have to be looking at you know that
again a lot of these smaller games now
these devs are able to make games that
look like AAA games yeah on much smaller
budgets small teams so why not do that
right why not you know again unity and
it's funny because when you drop YouTube
is horrible right and it evolved into
this thing that people kind of loved
and it's just to me so it kind of feels
like the you know unreal is taking over
the middle ground Now sort of that that
where it it's it's easy enough that the
small developer can take full advantage
of it and make a product that looks like
it's on par with a triple a product and
that's what you want if you can do it
right because Unity you can only get so
far with to really get the most out of
unity you got to really you gotta put
some effort into it right you can do
smaller stuff fairly easily but to make
it look like a UE you know engine file
you know a ue5 game you have to put the
work in so it's like there's that
balance and if you're telling me now hey
I can do this much easier on UE four and
five listen I yes the writing could have
been on the wall 100
um but at that time I don't know man it
just
this this feels like it's just such a
business decision removed from all of
the other like you made it you made it
in a silo with doors closed ears shut
down like you you listen to No One and
said this is what we're going to do and
you're gonna like it and no like there's
very few companies in the space that
could do something like that and get
away with it and you're like you're
gonna buy this anyway no they're not
when you're talking about these when
when they talk about constantly I'm
gonna yeah we're gonna shut down
yeah delist this game that people love
we're gonna delist it because we're not
feeling this so obviously you don't have
the leverage that you thought you had
and
it's gonna be a cold day when you turn
around be like what this backfire we're
shutting down and last question before I
passed the king do you think
they stand on it because this is the
most outraged I have ever seen Jeff
keighley made a statement I will say
that they haven't backtracked yet yeah
which is interesting they're standing on
them it's I don't I I think it gets
amended in some way shape or form
okay so there you go so it's like it's
not gonna be perfect it's not going to
be complete sort of repeal of what they
said they were going to do but I do
think they they have to sort of there's
too much backlash here for them to stand
on this square and watch and watch the
whole thing burn down because it's gonna
happen it's one of those things like as
Gamers it's funny because we say like
hey you know we never stand on our
Square we never we never really we say
vote with our dollars it never happens
right this is different because it's
Gamers outraged together with devs
outrage and devs will stand on their
Square devs will because at the end of
the day especially if you're looking at
a smaller product and be like you know
what
if we have to Railroad our game for
another year and a half or whatever no
in order in order to move it to another
another engine I'm hearing something
about yo we may be moving our joint over
to unreal I mean it's a lot of work it's
not like a flip the switch you've seen
you've seen the willingness to do it
because of how egregious this is so I
think I I think they amend in some way
shape or form I don't think it's going
to be enough for for everybody
um until they uh you know until they
decide to repeal it completely and I
don't know that that's gonna happen so
yeah I the World's Gonna burn on this
one bro it really is I do I do think
it's it's so weird man it's so weird
because you see it the packs you really
do see people excited about them on
Unity you never used to be trashed the
trash can laugh at it and I don't know
bro it's so weird it's so weird okay
[Laughter]
the level of greed is crazy I know Tim
Sweeney is like what like he he did what
uh no wonder my DMs was flooded like bro
when I get over there like yo they did
every time we go to packs
um we get a chance to talk to all the
devs majority of the games there of
these Indie devs are um Community facts
and the flexibility in the engines is
absolutely incredible what you can do
racing you can do indoor outdoor
Shooters you can do uh first person uh
third person you can do everything in
unity and it's the flexibility and ease
of use that helps developers if you have
small groups you know
the problem with this seems very
disingenuous you know they have ganshin
impact all these mobile games and do the
downloads right
so every time that mobile game is
downloaded to your phone
there goes that fee you understand
this is where it gets really spooky
they said this is not going to affect
the the large the the smaller uh
minority this is gonna affect well the
larger minority the larger majority this
is going to affect the smaller minority
the smaller minority being the
successful ones right so you're going to
look at game shouldn't impact and other
games of that ilk they use Unity yeah
now against an impact those they'll get
uh a bill yeah
now that Bill is for all the installs
right and they said oh we're not going
to go back into the past no from when
that when they updated their terms of
service and their fees that's when
that's going to go into effect from that
moment on
so when they say in January okay it's
gonna go into effect here on this date
nah retroactively from the day that you
updated it that's the day that you're
gonna get paid from right and you're
just giving a warning that in in January
this is going to go officially on the
books you know
the sad part about it is
consumer and Developers
this new course is going to set
different costs inside your projections
when you're you know when you go to
Price your game when you're going to
DLCs uh when you're starting to look at
things it could this be the end of the
DLC well this could be damn now at the
end of unity right because if this
practices is going to go over there you
just won't
Patron that wears but for those smaller
developers this is who I feel sorry for
yes those smaller developers that have a
game that they know is a Surefire hit
and at the same time they don't have the
ability to switch over to Unreal Engine
yeah they don't have the know-how and
the thing
yeah it's just you you just it's it you
took advantage
of a larger community that supported you
in the face of unreal let's be let's
keep it a buck facts when unreal
actually was showing you indoor outdoor
shooting and the Unreal Engine was being
pushed and it started powering some of
your most graphically intense games uh
and all that a lot of thought process
was with these consoles unreal is going
to be the de facto engine of use and for
the for the majority of the last
generation it was and now we see the
rise of unity in order for them to win
they said that we're going to cut off
our head to just throw it at the finish
line and this is absolutely ridiculous
yeah I just I've never seen anything
like this and the fact that he even
joked there had to be a joke we can
charge them a dollar to reload a clip
and again and that has to bro
he's mad but he was mad at Developers
for not monetizing their games more oh
yeah of course he's saying there's money
left on the table yeah he he's straight
big business like he's like and again
this is the you know the loot box oh gee
I mean obviously he's straight business
if he sold stocks before he went live
I mean obviously he said not my money
gonna be lost
I mean if if bro I heard of a certain uh
uh what is it um
female uh star that uh did the same
thing and she went away for a little bit
hello to her so um yeah yeah
Miss and we call it Ms over here
somebody need to go talk to your boy let
him know the feds are coming because the
hell out of here yeah I jump in this is
crazy like this is the wildest thing you
know I'm trying you know me I always try
to be balancing stuff but like this is
just super egregious in my opinion and
it's just it's like it's like you said
so like to me y'all know me like one of
my favorite things to interview the devs
right you're more than podcasting and
you know just because to me that's like
you're going to hear somebody's mixtape
for the first time before the world
knows that they're a star right and we
got him first and it's just like you
talking to him and then you know we go
through our questions but we always be
like yo this looks good what are you
using right and let's be honest back in
the day a you know it would be I would
say like 75 back in the day would be
Unity hey this is made on Unity you know
usually those guys are first time
starting that kind of thing and this is
just gonna suck because it's like at the
end of the day like
you're almost being penalized for being
successful right then
you're penalized for getting a bag from
the major Subscription Service holders
right so if you you know because we
already know for the most part you know
how Game Pass works a lot of times they
say Hey you know we think this is a you
know good fit for the service you know
is Microsoft coming to them and and then
it's like hey we project you to have
this many you know downloads or whatever
Revenue we think based on our excitement
for your title and then it's up to the
devil to say yeah man yo take that we'll
be ahead we can still work on the game
you know what I'm saying we got a bag we
got security right or something we'll
take the risk and say oh you know what
we'll wait we think you know maybe we
can do even better or whatever but it's
it's the offer of security right and
that's what makes Game Pass so
attractive I'm just thinking incorrect
you gotta correct me if I'm wrong addict
I'm thinking of a game like again I'm
not saying it's on Unity because I don't
know but I'm thinking of a game like sea
of stars
mm-hmm because they got a Game Pass back
and a PlayStation Plus bag now I don't
know if that game was uni but let's just
say it was right
do you the hit they're gonna get with
how popular the the influencer from
Chrono Trigger or the the yeah I think
that's where
they could do better on being
transparent yeah what are your motives
why do you feel this way do you feel
like the engine like that Unity itself
is being taken advantage of because
people are making all this money like
what are their motives I have a theory
because then I think we can really you
know break down to more of it it's like
look if if it is The Game Pass bags in
in the PlayStation bags and the you know
the old country Vegas Chad is saying
that see a stars is unity
that game is a lot arguably a game of
the year Contender yep it's that good
and think about it on PCS on wrong think
about every downloaded install that game
is gonna get it I got it I gotta tell
you about Theory I don't think the
majority of devs have an issue of a
price hike they realize
cost of goods go up
um I think it's just the the weird
language that they've chose to use it's
it's the fact that it doesn't seem like
Unity knows what the hell is going on
either because they can't answer
anything really well right I think
that's the issue uh you know if they
came out with a well-documented thing
how this is described how that's
described it you know I think the trust
me bro would be a little bit better it
it doesn't feel like this was well
thought of it feels like this this was
done over a couple weeks and you know
companies like that and I I see here's
the thing the one thing I will say about
Unity is if I was Unity
and I was seeing people get millions and
millions of dollars to use a game that's
created on my engine right to go into a
service such as Game Pass or PlayStation
Plus I would feel like okay maybe we
could come to some realization some
Middle Ground where you know you you
could you could compensate me for using
my engine to make that kind of money but
I think the way they're going about it
is not the way to do it I think that's
wrong what happened you sold the brick
he go and he blow up become rich Porter
you can't go back to him and say nah you
too successful
I gotta charge you more that's not
we know that is not but here's the thing
like maybe the way the engine system
needs to change slightly because it's
like you're offering the support you're
offering because obviously there's got
to be some kind of link between these
Studios and unity to to even have
support for this the system I mean maybe
it's so easy to use that they never need
a contact Unity that's that's the thing
they opted out of the 24-hour Protection
Service I'm gonna tell you what it is
and we offer our warranty our extended
warranty playing like now I'm good yeah
yeah I got y'all too
but then but then you what are we doing
on YouTube right now we're using another
service to voice our opinions on the
internet right uh they get 30 of the ad
Revenue correct they get 30 of
everything on Super Chat which way
from the beginning but no one's aren't
debating that okay we're debating on the
execution of how they've went about this
yeah absolutely absolutely that is the
issue that I see now you can debate on
whether or not Unity deserves a little
bit extra for me
let me finish man you can let me finish
okay
you can you could debate that but one
thing you can't debate is the essential
that Unity was used in that now
obviously they they need to be better on
being transparent with this because
there's too many devs using this that
don't know what's going on right and and
I think that's they have found out in
January that's the issue the issue is no
one knows what's going on the issue is
you know we don't know the mode is
behind this it
never mind he's laughing good finish
your thoughts stop being silly you
interrupted me by the way I was in the
middle of a point too and I let you rock
and now you get back I finished I'm good
all right he's good because I'm laughing
at the fact that what you saying is true
I don't know why he's being emotional I
don't know yeah but anyways what I was
saying
um was that
the two things here are they have a
minimal threshold as far as Revenue that
you can make in the 12 months and then
there's a minimal install count that
they have right so to me
the play I I think I know why they're
doing it if you look at Unity there's
like
you get the the student free version
right then you got like so it's like
Unity personal and then you know unity
plus right one is kind of like 399 and
one is like super cheap so in my opinion
it must be the devs are all on these
joints right then you got Unity Pro
right and then Unity Enterprise Edition
right so if you have those versions
here's the funny part if you are on the
the Enterprise of the pro they give you
way more threshold or how much money you
can make of course they give you way
much threat bigger threshold how many in
stores you can have so it goes from like
100 something two hundred thousand like
two million it's it's get them off our
free 99 version and they gonna pay this
bread for Office 365 it is the the
thirty dollar a Early Access soft field
model right here you go get if you give
us bread up front you're not gonna feel
this pain yeah and and I feel that I
feel that but they found that out too
late see if they they want to be nice up
front here use it yeah and that part and
then now the problem is now you actually
want to make money off of it and now
you're gonna look bad any which way you
do it right it's the same way as if we
put this podcast behind and we put our
Sunday podcast behind the paywall and
patreon y'all would murder us
no way
I had a free in the beginning yeah
exactly but so what I in my opinion
again corporate [__] they're looking at
the numbers right so let's just say to
attic's point
unreal is outside now unreal before you
should be only for the big guys right
you gotta afford it now the little guys
is like yo I could make a triple A
looking Banger and I unreal got the tool
that I got they got the netx they got
the lumens you don't say the Loomis is
popping news
let's say sweetie and them making it
easier for the Indie guy to get in
after this news came out right so now
you see you know so you can tell a look
at the Joint like how many of you guys
are on Unity games for gold
and they looking at the games for gold
Unity dude and they like die fam we
gotta get these dudes out of here and
they we got to get them so if you want
if you want that if you on that game to
go the person with student Edition
if you make this amount of bread you
gonna owe us
I I hate the B Corp recall but I think
that's what's going on here I think they
are trying to change that number and
yeah it's crazy because
um you know you got that the last thing
I said I think Attica appreciate this
is
you know obviously we we've heard a lot
about John vicatello during this
conversation
the funniest thing is y'all know who sue
the 51 is all right you know no more
Heroes at all that job oh yeah so
apparently
when John riccatello was the CEO of I'm
going to steal but he worked at EA
before
he sued his time with him and working
with him on his game at the time I think
was Travis something something
yes yes
he made suda's life such a Liberty Hill
as far as trying to get this game out
and telling him he need to change this
and he need to do this and do that that
shooter rewrote the game and put John
riccatello as the main antagonist in his
game as the boss that you could beat up
and rough up and the only thing he
changed was the first name to date from
John to Damon or something like that he
put He hate this man so much he put him
as the boss in his game since you can
kill him rough up that is wild that is
wild so yeah and the last thing is um I
was just gonna say was just that um we
got to see I know who was talking about
it you know is there grounds for a class
action you know based on this the the
terms of service change you know and do
they have a stand-in because I know devs
are inquiring they want it like they're
unified against Unity so yeah it's gonna
be it's a crazy situation I've never
seen anything like this and
yeah that that's the unity situations
that's great I mean Tim Sweeney is
salivating salivating because you like
they don't I don't think unreal charges
you uh anything to use the left you make
your first million million right
yes
over here then we want to dig in your
wallet
yeah so the first million is yours first
million sales right first million sales
or first million dollars sales
so if it's sales it's much more than a
million dollars
that's crazy that's crazy so we gonna
get you right and then you're gonna get
us right go get it right
you didn't even these other dude said oh
they over there winning with the stuff
that we gave them
getting their pockets yeah I think I
think it's really competitive and like I
said maybe with unreal's growth in the
space and they're declining Revenue
maybe they you know they let go they're
putting their foot down we got to get
this this bread if you want to stay
alive or stay around for a while but
we'll see adding anything else anybody
got anything else before we move on from
this topic good all right so let's go to
super chats and then uh cool move on to
the next one so did you guys read any of
them yeah
okay so where do we leave off er I'm
gonna say
let me put on the fan fun day let me go
back all right I'm gonna say
up um
outside
Doctor Strange Love with the five
dollars in the chat sorry for stop being
late y'all that was on me because you
were playing our favorite games and I
like to call hide the Jordans
[Laughter]
[Music]
he got here late man no oh man ain't
getting no music today
then we got Forza Legend five dollars of
attack playing MK1 as I watch the Lords
this is the greatest MK story ever and I
mean ever shout out to Ed Boone and boo
but his legacy in fighting games yeah
bonus bro it's not even close when it
comes it's funny because the other day I
downloaded uh the making of karateka
oh how the Puerto Ricans said
um and they have the little like uh what
the documentary part of it and I saw
John Tobias there I was like wow oh
Legends
we got Danny passion official two
dollars
MK1 story is fire I think that's what it
was good they did an amazing job with it
that is nice I think we have jfx 88 five
dollars for the chat speaking of game
bosses Idol from Killer Instinct on SNES
whoop me for days I remember
that SNES version too which is not great
but you know it was not meant to run on
that
then we have Lucy's Augustus five
dollars Super Chat imagine Adobe asking
YouTubers to pay-per-view because they
use their tools to edit the video you
uploaded you can easily owe more than
you make yeah
is on it and we got Robert Kelly Two
Dollars a chat Unity going to be next in
the MS shopping list I'll tell you right
now I want to know how Microsoft feel
about Unity saying they got they got it
they got the building they got the bill
that's on them don't worry about it
dying to hear Microsoft subsidizing this
for you guys
pushed back I'm like when we ain't doing
that and unity games ain't gonna be over
like it could get crazy the thing is
yeah you're right okay you need to just
they didn't have a better business plan
going into the thing and and now I think
with as many people going over to Unreal
they're trying to find other ways to
monetize it's like this isn't the way
you know like I saw people in the chat
saying oh I had to hear crazy to Unity
thing and I never said I agree with the
thing I literally said Unity gotta go
it's just like you you can't play the
middle ground at all in these streets or
people think you're the left or right I
know what you're saying because it's
like what you're saying is you're trying
to understand like how they got there
right like how did they get to this
determination
that's my thing it's like I how do you
come to this decision and not and then
sound it like seem like you're oblivious
to why the backlash is happening and you
acting like you ain't hurting nobody
like this is not gonna really affect
anybody just if you make too much money
yo
then we have uh twink 89 Welcome To The
Ground Lord so we're putting the Crush
in the chat
in the house absolute then we got Gamers
play HUD x0 uh five dollars for chat
Unity wants the bag badly greedy indeed
have affiliate Xbox looking at this very
closely Game Pass will be affected tools
money per download yeah that's the real
conversation
gay press whole model is downloaded yeah
like they hold Jordan is how many is
engagement I don't think that thing is
Gonna Fly with them so yeah
because the attic point they not you
would have bro Jeff Kegley was outside
something like this I feel like they
would have already back yeah like if
they were going to they would have done
it by now he already sold his stocks
is the impression that he has not talked
to either Phil or um or whatever call it
a PlayStation about this the impression
is this is news to everybody
that night
and he was like yo they going in there
so they was like yo he was like yo I'm
going over there to the VIP area he was
like nah this is uh for only the
gangster impact that
um you know they they brought out the
area he said what yeah the city of stars
brought out the other VIP over there so
wait a second wait a second there's a
dudes accusing Unity
and he says you know something and
they're like in a bar or a club whatever
he's like let me get 10 bottles of this
it's on him yo Jamie Foxx look to the
side
that's a wild practical joke
[Music]
you know who he is
and what's crazy shout out to us
Technica they had an article they say
what was surprising for developers it
says in 2015 save John uh riccatello was
publicly touting you to these no
royalties no effing around subscription
plan like that was the sell to the Devil
he's like
he said now
dude he was like he's a Madman yo
literally he was on his soapbox like
this is what we do
over yeah with this ten toes down for
Life till death do his part and then you
gotta serve papers
bro it's crazy so yeah they looking into
these terms of service people are really
good okay I don't know if you say
anything good or whatever okay yes black
roller 357 remember for 19 months Lord
silver Unity just sent customers to the
competition state of play was mid and
Final Fantasy barely saved it started
with the still by Game of the Year happy
Lord's day to uh to all Philly stand up
absolutely
I got Robert Kelly Two Dollars of attack
Unity doing its job devs are unified
that was good that was good they
definitely cutified on this then we got
blue with the two dollar Super Chat it's
an epic by unity Microsoft buy you the
thing is anybody who buys Unity at this
point right maybe Microsoft epic doesn't
have a use for it yeah they don't they
would they would literally shudder the
whole thing if they bought it like and
just absorb the devs absorb the devs
into fortnite I guess and to me it's
like you need Unity around for
competition like you know what I'm
saying for another engine but yeah I
mean I will say this though attempts
when he's not the type of dude that he's
not he never rests on his Laurels like
oh no yeah he so even if with the comp
you're always gonna get pushed right but
Tim soon is never really gonna rest on
his Laurels like that so
you remember when he was fighting over
uh what is it when Microsoft
yeah he don't play they don't play they
don't play he'd be battling and his
snitch game yeah
wow he all about getting more Revenue to
the dev and he wanting to put on your
other store and yeah he's going to war
right now for Apple
then we got Robert Kelly Two Dollars to
the chat Pokemon go card mobile genjen
all run on units is a crazy problem
all those three yeah
then we got Pony up two dollars a chat
does Lily Mo use Unity should Colin be
concerned I think he said the game maker
right oh yeah maybe I'll hit up um I'll
hit up Barry and I'll head up because
they had a lily mole and um
that's a good question I I do not know
the answer so I'm gonna actually hit him
up man in January we all find out
when he's standing on the other side of
the line hell no we won't go
we'll call it outside it'll be real I
think he's got a secret about I gotta I
ever get a chance to check it out yep
we got country big 94. five power Super
Chat evening Lord Starfield main story
complete and amazing time definitely my
game of the year so far even played it
on xcloud last night and was working
perfectly shout out
what's up then we got the god Emperor
sofa king with the five dollars of a
chat people need uh to keep the
situation people need to keep the
situation when in my in mind when
pushing devs to use third-party engines
like Unity are unreal
I mean the third party is still the best
solution you when you build your own
engine uh hello uh Halo infinite it's
unless you keep everybody in-house yeah
it's a problem it's a problem
then we got Cedric h10 chat
um the toughest boss that I fought in a
fighting game was God rugoff in Capcom
it took me literal hours facts yeah
remember gill from Street Fighter three
oh Jesus Christ yes yes
and we got JD gamer five dollars chat
acquisition talk and we need Microsoft
to buy both iron Galaxy and another Rome
because we need some serious high
quality exclusive fighters on the box oh
I'll take me some nether Brown
I'm excited for when they decide they
want to do something else too yes yes
I used to like that remember when they
did the Mortal Kombat RPG yeah yeah
allowed them to experiment a lot like
you know the PlayStation platform with
the CD opened up everything for us yeah
okay give me one second then we got JD
gamer I got five dollar Super Chat
Microsoft buy Sega iron Galaxy and
another realm I want a crazy good slate
of Fighters with both good mechanics and
story lore basically 2024 fighters
fighters Mega mix oh fight his Mega mix
I've ever met I used to terrorize people
with the Daytona Car
s this one's Sega said we don't care no
more we don't care about somebody I want
to know who's in charge when it is like
Fighters mega mega you had the Daytona
Carson that is the most amazing game but
yo imagine imagine Sega gets purchased
and they decide you know what it's time
to bring back Virtual Fighter oh my God
virtual fighter that would be crazy you
can't make it
Suzuki
like no I'm talking about the game won't
make it in this market like the last one
they did and they turned it into like a
game of service yeah yeah yeah it was
five right weird they released five a
bunch of different times yeah it was
just weird it was just they they
couldn't gain their footing I they
didn't evolve like tekkeny Tekken
evolved into different areas I think the
fact that this was built off of like a
fighting simulator it hampered them
because it kept them grounded and when
they tried to dispel uh reality it
didn't transcend well I don't know they
just seemed like they stuck in a pass
yeah it's not gonna be like they bring
back Virtual Fighter right and you're
right if you're gonna survive in this
day and age like look at Tekken Tekken
has a whole lot more explosions than it
ever did before but there's a lot of a
lot of sparks flying and like and Tekken
was a little more grounded right so yeah
and I don't know how I would feel if
they try to do that to Virtual Fighter
like I'd be mad actually so yeah
and that's it we're caught up all right
cool cool so right on time this is huge
you got crew state of plays directs what
you what you wouldn't do all right you
know what is this jump into the crew
first to talk a little bit about the
crew um
so the crew motorfest all the Lords had
an opportunity to play it shout out to
uh Ubisoft office codes shout out to you
yourself for those codes and the crew
motorfest is the third game in the crew
uh sort of series uh the first one was
kind of kind of like a street racing
type of game the second one went it was
more along the lines of like a true sort
of like Motorsport event where it was it
tried to simulate this sort of World
ride across across the United States
sort of uh feel
um it added I don't remember the first
crew had multiple types of vehicles but
the crew two definitely added like
flying vehicles motorcycles things of
that nature and it was more like an open
world thing and now the crew motor Fest
is quite frankly an homage to Forza
Horizon it really is it really is homage
imitation is the clearest form or
flattery yes oh very sincere very very
very sincere
um but it is that essentially what it
what it does if it's a much smaller game
that focuses on uh a sort of uh a
festival right of those sorts in Hawaii
that has basically the same type of
things you would see from Horizon where
it has like different sort of playlists
different sort of biomes for you to go
uh back and forth in different cars
um and it has this whole sort of festive
Festival Vibe where it's like a
celebration of of car culture
um it is more on the arcady side right
so this is not a Sim sort of racer
um it also still includes the boats and
the motorcycles although I kind of do
feel like it's taking the backseat to
the actual cars
um the game plays well the game is
pretty
um in in spots where it really shines
especially on the PC I think it really
really shines
um I had trouble playing it on the Rocks
because it has some sort of weird thing
where
um the dead zones for the triggers are
all messed up so in order to accelerate
you had to like literally like just
almost break your trigger button your
trigger button on the Rock and it was a
net could never get it right so I had to
wait to be able to play it on my PC
um all in all it it emulates Forza and
it doesn't do it as well it's not it you
know Forza is still this ridiculous sort
of crazy package but
I think they're on the right track and
in terms of you know maybe trying to
create their own little space within
this space because Horizon has it locked
out and the idea The Horizon is never
going to go to other vehicles right it's
going to be about cars so if they can
sort of focus on on improving those
other aspects of this game that makes it
different to Horizon
um
I think they'll find success in addition
to the fact that if you're somebody who
doesn't play on Xbox at all don't have
Game Pass you're not going to be playing
Horizon right so this is the game that's
going to be on every platform and I
guarantee you this game is probably in
development for the new Nintendo it's
going to be a launch game for the new
Nintendo okay for sure
um so I like it I like it I think it's a
solid start it obviously emulates a lot
of what what you know and love about
Horizon and it and it and it feels like
a good it's a tight racer it's good but
it's it's not quite there but yeah but
as something a little bit different
um it's funny because one of the first
things they do is something that people
have uh kind of uh criticized Forza
Horizon for not doing yet is going to
Japan so one of those playlists
right in Japan
yeah I ain't gonna front yeah so that
was like that was trying to stick it to
them a little bit yeah yeah we did that
with your fan base want this we got that
yeah that's a good one that's a good one
so the the game is pretty uh it it does
a lot of stuff right and it's an
entertaining uh racing game but it's
like you know if you've played Forza
Horizon you know the inspiration and it
doesn't quite live up to that but it's
good in its own right attic your
thoughts the crew I really enjoyed it
you know I've put about 10 hours into it
give or take uh you know it's it
definitely very inspired by Horizon but
I feel like
The Horizon formula works really well
with a casual audience so that makes the
most sense you know that and but you
know we gotta bring up too that like
is this like a lot of hints from Horizon
yeah but you know there's a lot of hints
from the crew in here as well now you
could switch from a vehicle to you know
a um a plane to a uh a boat and I it
gets like really unique little aspects
they got their own like little Battle
Royale thing in here uh you know they
got a lot of modes that you can play
they got a showroom you know this game
is centered around the vehicles you use
and that's what I like about it I think
that's why Horizon was always successful
it's because it it doesn't send you
around like the universe for the most
part or or people in the game or
anything like that centered around the
universe the only time I've ever seen a
racing game that's casual do well
that's not centered around the vehicles
was like the original Need for Speed
most Wanted with The Blacklist like
because that was centered around The
Blacklist but it worked out very well
for them I think I think they got them
something here you know that this
formula redefine this
make it more beefy and I think you know
uh this is the first time I've ever
played a casual game a casual racing
game that I felt like Horizon actually
might have competition now but you know
this this is the only thing that I could
see when it comes to a casual audience
it's like Need for Speed lift that you
look at this I'm like okay I could see I
could see it now like and it's fun man I
really enjoyed playing no doubt King
thoughts on the crew I turned it on and
I said what the hell I didn't put on uh
Forza
and I I was just looking I was like yo
this is like fun in the U.S finding the
alien ship and we reverse engineer it
it kind of looked like it
it's almost just like it but just a
little bit different got a little twist
to it they didn't reverse engineer it
properly so it felt it falls short in a
lot of spots but it also excels
in areas that
um Horizon can't excel in right and it's
not even the Horizon like cutting itself
they just they they just don't do it
structure did yeah in those areas they
don't do it you looked at somebody's uh
they came out first
and you have the ability to come behind
and make improvements I mean and that's
exactly what you're supposed to do
especially if you're gonna come out and
clone somebody you better be the best
damn clone that you can be like but you
got a little Quirk which your clone with
a quirk you you probably got a twitch
with your head or something different
than the original so but I do like the
f-zero I mean um the the Formula One
yeah
so you go it's it's when you're starting
the game in the beginning you pick your
character you customize your character
whatever then you get into cars and then
going from section to section kind of
like Horizon did right where you went
through the Baja you went on the street
they did the same exact same intro where
you when you get to the festival right
yeah and then they got the corny talking
hey guys
it's probably the same time length too
it's like they took one of the second in
command and four or is that I was like
copy what you did over there yeah yeah
it's like they got somebody from
playground when I left
access companies say hey look guys I got
a great idea for our second game
but again you know it excels in
different areas two different games but
very similar in the beginning and the
approach all right so you're gonna have
to play a little bit more to get past
the similarities in the game there's a
little bit of limitations but there's a
little bit of uh exploration that's
afforded to you and the crew opposed to
Horizon now I could say this if you like
Horizon and you're looking for something
that has a little bit more a little bit
different but has that same familiar
feel to it the crew is definitely
something that I can recommend because
you know it's it's a lot different from
the previous crew games yes this game is
actually stepping out even though it
seems like they had a huge inspiration
big brother must have saved a life
that they was little Joe remember when
usually Big Joe out there I'm a little
Joe like yeah this would have like you
know big Horizons saved them so they the
little you know little Horizon crew
I understand I know the devil is not
going to be upset because but the fact
of the matter is this yeah to be given
that High Praise because Horizon is
fantastic and for the worst thing that
we can say about your product is that it
emulates the best open World Racing game
that's in the market right now that puts
you up in verified air and if we didn't
say the frame rate was a problem if we
didn't say the handling was a problem if
we didn't say the storyline was a
problem that means that you have a great
game on your hands and you're being
compared to the best yeah yeah and one
thing I do want to point out too is like
this is the best time to have a game
like this Horizon isn't coming out this
year so it's like motorsport's going to
get some of those casuals that thought
that would think like Horizons a similar
game when it's not right and then it's
like we got fours over here for it and
so if Forza doesn't work for you the
crew over here is a good solid
experience for that for that for that
casual Forza Horizon thing yeah no I
agree with everything all y'all said um
obviously got a chance to play I gotta
look I'll be honest I came in hating
because I was like man we gotta play
this and I want to play other stuff but
I go live but yeah that's what we talk
about right like but I got front I was
pleasantly surprised I was like first
off the rip look I Gotta Give it the
graphics are absolutely gorgeous like at
least my TV HDR 10 when you change it
from the RGB to HDR 10 I put it on
performance mode 60 frames it is ripping
and wrong it looks crazy fantastic the
car models look fantastic the lighting
looks amazing the playlist I agree with
King are really cool it's really fun
like you go from off-road that is you
know they've made it in Japan that Japan
was the direct shot and I was like oh
that was it it kind of made me think
that
you should have just doubled down and
went in Japan yeah dude
do the horizon
the the the infrastructure you should
have took it where they won't take it
yeah yeah absolutely that would have
made it stand out even more for sure I
mean they got the Japanese music they
got the whole little mini storyline with
the crew you know
very authentic the light at night time
we've been wanting that from four years
so take me back to um Midnight Club yes
that yeah it's Tokyo drift racing and
all that yeah bro get your um exhaust yo
your turbo will be making that yeah now
I'm glad you said that because I'm I'm
gonna hold on to that that's literally
another joint that I like from them but
before I get that what you also said
about the Motorsport Indie style Formula
One style right for the guys that want
to get low you know what I'm saying do
that of course they don't do that before
they don't do that and I believe there
was a pit mechanic or some joints
yeah from the tires I was like yo they
got that like and again it's just quick
it's boom boom you get they put you in a
joint and just go go go it wasn't you
got
they took the festival out of Forza
Horizon and they spun it with the crew
in it yeah so the pla what it is that
playlist system is kind of fire because
it's just like boom go to the next you
go to the next and it's always something
to do a cool different fun you know look
we got to call it how it is they are
heavily inspired by Forza Horizon also
um you know down to the throw down to
the the festival situation down to like
they even got a the the the GPS with the
or like I'm like damn they got the
playlist beat they got the rewind they
come like they got they got the virtual
assistant the virtual assistant they got
they got the UI the fonts yeah some of
the I'm like bro phone is a playground
sometimes you got you got you gotta it's
like that Meme where it's like can I
copy your homework yet but just change
the things
but hey I like cake said yo if you go
and do come through why not you know go
at the best I mean and try to improve on
the best to be fair yeah
Horizon has been the only casual like
racing type the way it is that has hit
the masses the way it acts like if
you're going to be inspired by the best
like Horizons the only game that's done
that yeah no absolutely and to me I got
to give them credit it's fun now again
where I go back to King to me the the
actual driving of the car I can't say
it's better than all right so like the
way the Horizon control but this game is
mad fun what I will give them over
Horizon
to me the game changes what you said
King is that Nitro button so it's like a
catch-up mechanic on the straightaways
or like that adds to the push pull
remember how excited I was telling y'all
but I was about oh you missed us all I
had been in the episode 99 like that
bro they did it I I didn't it was the
Battle Royale thing I didn't know I
needed
um so amazing I was playing that for
hours but what makes f-zero is that
little ketchup mechanic they got the
thing you get into the Skyway you can
Turbo with them with this Nitro you
could still get up in the mix you know
what I'm saying and I thought that was a
cool strategic element so yeah yeah the
crew I gotta I gotta admit pleasantly
surprised definitely definitely happy
about what I play so far it's a little
bit like burnout especially Burnout
Paradise and some some instances as well
so it's fast and you're spinning yeah
yeah it has a lot of Inspirations it had
a lot of Inspirations and hey to me keep
going down this path forget about that
worldwide stuff because again if unless
you dedicate the time and effort it kind
of feels like a game like that is only
something that a team like a Forza
Horizon team could really focus on and
try to do uh
dwindle it down to something specific
and focus on that and I think they'll be
okay I got it yeah yeah and I was gonna
say you keep in mind I don't know if you
guys said it uh Ubisoft did provide us
all for it totally absolutely uh and you
know shout out to them because uh
because they you know Ubisoft what I
what I like to give them uh credit for
is like especially when it comes to
content creation they let us keep it
real you know they don't really try to
like get you to hold your punches in any
way shape they're like here's your codes
and I thought I thought it was a bit of
confidence on their part obviously
they're willing to show that I believe
for anyone there's a demo right now you
can play five hours of it right so if
you don't have it you guys like what you
heard you know go check it out for
yourself you know I'm saying but this
was our opinion on it but solve I know
we still got the other parts of the
topic you want to do the uh stay the
play yeah which one do you which one do
you guys want to go to first
let's end on PlayStations
caffeine for this oh man all right so
yeah yeah so let me read these super
chats first
come on board Saga ten dollars Microsoft
would be the perfect home for Unity it
already uses C plus and its default IDE
is Visual Studio Regulators would never
let it happen though also that new Nas
album is fire hashtag free knocker keep
them right where he is
hashtag keep it right after after we
heard spoke to Peter boy uh I can't rock
and chew on that level I'm
let's go then we got JD game with ten
dollars Super Chat idea split VF and
Virtual Fighter into two paths one
grounded in realism taken to the nth
degree a la fight night and other uh and
other paths blessed uh by the gods that
modernizes the virtual virtual fighter
and allows fantasy lore get nether realm
to help okay yeah why not I mean you
could do what again we kind of stuck in
our ways of like if you bring back
Virtual Fighter it's one thing it's you
know all this stuff is fake you get
crazy stuff with it and then you know
whatever so yeah why not I just want to
see Virtual Fighter back
um Robert Kelly chat I guess Horizon 5.5
came out this year after all oh yeah 5.5
it's it's heavily inspired heavily
that's it we're caught up right this is
you so we going we're doing all right
yeah Nintendo Direct all right and I
gotta say man Nintendo
I gotta say yeah you know they just
again we all it's pretty much I I pretty
much believe that the next Nintendo uh
platform will be out next year at some
point end of the year probably
um but Nintendo still keeps Trucking
along because they're gonna keep
continue to try to continue to sell you
uh switches right and I'll be honest man
I saw this direct I was like wow okay
they still got a little something in the
chamber uh they have you know they they
come out I don't have it in order here
right but they announced obviously the
remake of the Thousand Year Door that
was a GameCube game quickly interrupt
unrelated because I know the realm did
ask me earlier yeah Colin just hit me
back um perils and his games are not on
Unity he's he's not so he he good he's
he hit me back I think I think it was
Game Maker right yeah it's probably game
maker yeah he just hit me right now but
I'm sorry yeah so uh yeah so we get like
a remake or a remaster of Thousand Year
Door probably I think most people's most
beloved Paper Mario game was the
GameCube one right or the original
um so we have that HD announcing yeah it
just still makes me wonder how many of
these HD remakes whether it be from the
game
we they have to have a bolts of these
silicone
boy I got thoughts
the crazy thing is they're gonna give
you these remake slash remasters right
and at some point I really do think they
are doubling down on the the whole you
know uh subscription thing right I think
that transfers over to whatever the new
Nintendo console is but they're gonna
give they're gonna give you they're
gonna give you the old version
pay for it in perpetuity and they go and
they're gonna give you nice dressed up
version
you know with makeup on and everything
and then you're gonna pay for that and
then eventually they're gonna take the
new version and throw it in there too
and make you pay for it in perpetuity
again right yeah lay down so next remake
Mario versus Donkey Kong remake is
coming
ah so that is cool I never played that I
never played that but it looks like a
nice you have the opportunity now yes I
do I do that's why Nintendo did that for
you nice crazy Graphics he's getting his
legs in yeah you ready he ready you
already see me spinning it yeah yeah and
and then I gotta agree with cargo on
this one at F zero 99. I've been to me
I've been to New York I'll play it bro
bro you came with Pac-Man 99 same with
Texas
ah you gotta relax
it's such a difficult game on his own
already and for them to do this to it
and it'll be like okay you now you have
no agency whatsoever it's like it's a
lot of it is luck a lot of it is you
trying to really stay kind of in the
middle of the track and not get bumped
off yeah and the sheistiness if
feels like original Mario Kart levels of
shy steam yes and you know what reminds
me of two just in terms of how it feels
it's it's uh
wrestling Battle Royal I'll pull you out
for you out of the rig trip your leg
like stupidness I used to hate you know
foolishness that you never you can never
ever feel safe ever in fact so you said
hey y'all
the Revenge you gotta you gotta make
things happen you cost me a lot of
matches too oh yeah don't get close to
the roads bro we right there
so we got that that was really really
awesome
um then we got Princess Peach
the Princess Peach game finally gets a
um a title and it's coming out it's
coming out next year right
um
so yeah cool I wish I don't I don't know
that it really feels like a platformer
it kind of feels like half platformer
half kind of trying to do a little bit
of Animal Crossing stuff where it's like
you can dress Peach up and all this
stuff yeah but I like the fact that the
suits all have sort of their uh their
own different powers it's a it's kind of
like battling on the world done right
yes
the man locked down then
we have
three masters of three of the greatest I
think anyway uh old school games of all
time Tomb Raider one two and three
looking nice and crisp crispy although I
hope they control more modern yeah I
don't wanna I don't want to be jumping
back two squares in order to jump over I
don't want tank control so maybe maybe
they kind of rejiggered that coming off
of Xbox in February right yes it is
for everybody does it count yeah
everybody so don't get excited
it's for everybody then on to the next
yeah
some people sound salty today man yeah
yeah yeah they went back and looked at
their show they salty with the King
today
oh I watched this one very quickly fine
go down the column when you go down the
columns it's like oh that that's not
exclusive
[Laughter]
uh-huh then we got let me see oh the
next remaster on the list Luigi's
Mansion two HD now see remasters there's
nothing wrong with that oh like that
y'all didn't have no remasters over
there so you can't go there but what we
can do today is I can for the price of
one you can have fun
deck what's Final Fantasy VII remake
it's a remix
that was one of the reasons why I got a
three oh my Lord I said I gave that I
gave your remake a double Point
yeah would have been one without this
keep taking baby steps hey you
there we have we have splatoon's DLC you
can continue to add to Splatoon three
um yeah PVE story stuff
that's original yeah then we got King's
favorite game Prince of Persia the Lost
crime
multi-plat yeah you're multi-platform me
prop that game up
for the streets
we got another look at Mario RPG still
looking very very nice what's up with
that dope body Blue Rock them yeah isn't
that remake or something elbow shots
that is a remake yes that's nice
because I got to make sure I have a set
time I've never played that and people
yeah I've never played it though I've
never played people tell me that's like
the best the best hustle yeah it also
came on and it was seen you don't even
talked Raves about it and by the way
Chad we the reason why there's a lot of
sarcasm is if y'all didn't watch our
live stream for the PlayStation showcase
you know King had thoughts about his
review on why he rated that showcase
certain way so we were just talking
about I should have cut that out and
played it at the beginning
so we just you know there's a little
infighting with the Lords right now
yeah
thanks so we got uh we got trombone
champions again when it came out on PC I
think bro the joint with the yeah
yeah because it's just about foolishness
it's just about foolishness and and
playing the trombone badly yeah
the best question I can ask about that
is that multiply
everything nobody was telling me nah it
looked like it was using old school
weeds there ain't nobody rocking with
that yeah you're still taking babies and
it was using it was using proprietary
yeah
remember what you opened the show with
yeah we got yeah it looks funny no
matter what he says I can't yeah
then we got Dave the diver
that's the game I remember uh the sushi
game Kyrie and kaibatu was telling me
about that he was in love with that so
he really enjoyed that it's just coming
oh yeah it's a black man in Japan
the whole game makes no sense
I was I was doing it with the coin I was
just doing that we got let me see let me
see what else we got the final piece of
DLC finally for Mario Kart 8 the booster
course pass yes I don't know how many
damn tracks in that game now
uh detective Pikachu returns getting
another trailer
amiibos that still sell like crazy
that's how you show that's how you show
a peripheral
s
if the crew motifs is not for you then
you have Horizon Chase too
you saw that racing
definitely not running that 60s no it
definitely wasn't it wasn't on the phone
stars level uh God bless then we getting
like hell divers though
you gotta winner baby then we got
another Wario wear coming people just
not super happy with the last Mario rare
so that's cool
they sell like hot chicks
yo listen I gotta win anybody by any
means necessary I see I see the
standings
and then we have another code
recollection which is a compilation of
game or one game that originally came
out two games that came out on the DS
one of which never came to the states
and they both came yeah and they were
released later on the weekend
right now new games
I love how he's repping them just by
proxy because he wants to put the other
ones down exactly that's how we do it
out here
and then they got they got two again
this Square Enix sort of small RPG sort
of uh Factory still keeps pumping them
out we have a saga in The Saga series we
have a new game called Saga Emerald is
coming next year Emerald yeah
and then finally we have unicorn
Overlord which is a new tactics RPG from
the guys that made 13 sentones 13
Sentinels was the game a couple years
ago 13 Essentials people was touted for
having like one of the best narratives
people love that narrative that
narrative was crazy crazy
so uh All In All For What Nintendo does
including their first party stuff
I forgot you forgot to um I thought it
was big I gotta get back I gotta give
them that they had uh you know I don't
even care about this but I know it's big
they had this Sora for um
no he's a character they had the amiibo
for him oh he's he's been in the game
they also announced uh the Nintendo
Museum that's being built so you can go
there and spend even more money you see
I have to go see Nintendo stuff come out
and talk Nintendo with nintendites um
this is uh again this is in line what
Nintendo does they They're bringing back
a lot of their old franchises remaking
and remastering them for people you know
don't have access to them anymore
um and I think switch switch is the is
the Baseline now for all that stuff and
they just keep bringing them out and I
know they have a bunch more in waiting
in the chamber you feel like me they got
they still got more stuff than they can
show they still got yo you feel
me that's crazy where's that wind way
good where's that would wake up
that's us where was this energy on what
PlayStation could or could not have
shown uh we get to that when we talk
about the places what did y'all think of
this
I thought it was an okay show I thought
it showed the I guess to me like I only
care about their stuff and the games
that I was interested I already knew
about
so it's just like one of those things
where it's like oh
what you said the stuff that you was
interested in you already knew about so
it made this show yeah you know it
didn't make it and lukewarm okay
it was cool like all right so stuff that
you knew about
and you already knew it was gonna be
there all right let's go let's go
that energy feel good see here's the
thing though I've watched these for
myself and I cared more about Final
Fantasy 7 Re Barriers that I cared about
everything everything in the world yeah
he played for a day and then you're
gonna go back and say ah it's not what I
thought it was
that's future addicts problems
so uh a king I'm assuming this is a
raving oh my God yo I thought this show
was at eight
I love everything about this show it was
so Nintendo it felt Nintendo oh my God
it didn't get bogged down and you know
needing this uh chatter they didn't show
games over and over again you know like
what I like about Nintendo is when they
talk about something man we're gonna
give you a separate Direct on that when
that's about to come out but we're not
gonna keep showing you the same thing
and every you know direct you know
because we got games you know we the
house in this yo this is the house
scenario built you know
um
peaches peaches peaches he put it on his
back man you realize their biggest games
they have showed multiple times right
yeah the biggest game what's that what
was that Mario and Donkey Donkey I saw
that I saw that that day she came before
they showed the show they showed them
they showed the title of peach bro If
You're Gonna Keep It Funky Keep It Funky
bro they showed the title of Peach and
said get ready for her she's showing up
back to you
okay
just in case you would show up but I
thought the show was incredible like I
said you know the the f-zero yes
um
Nintendo man what can I say y'all y'all
doing it again man yeah yeah
yo you know the best thing about [__]
what Cog said he said yo I had a problem
with F0 then I found out Nintendo which
Nintendo don't ever do for the game day
and day for free in a service that's a
fact though you know in a service for
free I've been doing that a lot here
like I was able to partake and his mind
changed
day in day changes people's mind and
perception of the game and he's able to
boost it up so that alone makes this
show something incredible that that
alone it has turned the the the the the
into the Saints you know because he's in
the beginning he's on his nonsense
he got a chance to touch he realized he
has a newly converted f-zero what is it
um
so hey I appreciate you had a great
direct and I understand it after your
direct it also changed your life I
didn't say all that I said that's zero
and zero but yeah yeah yeah yeah I see
what he hold the line with Nintendo over
here oh yeah look this joint you know
it's decent it's a great show for for
first party Nintendo that's King the
last time he was on his switch anyway
you know you're for real but you don't
got my social security number
and he's like you can't check the
credential so I'm good yeah for me look
a lot of people you know their first
party definitely showed out you know as
far as for me personally outside of the
episode of Mario Kart the um the Tomb
Raider I thought was cool Prince of
Persia I count you know it's fact that
it's a multi-plat on this stage and it's
coming I I count that Dave the diver was
out already but I count that that's a
huge game you know what I'm saying
that's coming to the platform and you
know they continue this more smash but I
have come to realizations of I've come
to realization with Nintendo that I'm
the complete opposite of addict like
attic is there for the first part I like
I realized their first party does
nothing for me I am not the Target
demographic for their first party at all
so I when I listen to them and they'd be
like and then the music come on
and it'd be like oh you're bringing back
the classic insert old Nintendo Port
here with 60 frames per second and new
new grab new updated graphics reimagined
for when I hear that I'm tuned up it's
like you literally going through every
aspect of your back catalog to recharge
for sixty dollars because you run a lot
of stuff like that that to me I'm not
there with them on that now granted I
know there is going to be fomo for a lot
of the hard to get games let me push
back yeah go please do please do if
you're not there for like when it comes
to like the switch Nintendo for the
first party like what are you
specifically yeah I don't I think their
first party's whack I don't I don't like
none of their first part the only thing
I like from they first party I'm gonna
be 100 is Zelda I'm kind of done with
Mary I'm kind of doing Mario in all
these different situations I'm kind of
done with Mario Tennis Mario Diddy Kong
Mario Paper Mario it's like bro y'all
keep remixing so much like just I'm good
on that like again I'm not I'm not gonna
that's what I should say the games are
good I am not the Target demographic
that is for the new Young Generation of
kids who don't know and they like yo you
know what I'm saying and it's fun and
it's for them it's just not for me you
know I'm saying now when there's certain
ones that of course we all gonna have
our fomo nostalgic joint right f-zero
they got me I bet I mean of course but
theoretically it's them digging in the
grades right they ain't giving me a new
episode game just to clarify yeah you
don't care about first party until
something that's your flavor no I don't
care about really I don't think their
first party is good that's just me they
don't it doesn't appeal to me I'm not
here for Pokemon I'm not here for Kirby
I'm not here I like you know what I've
done the taco go after you yeah I know
and I love I love saying what I say he
don't like Sega great all right I don't
really care for Nintendo like that like
I've always been a second
yeah
I've always been consistent that he
looked at the the Mario and denied him
nah I'm older now like you gotta like
when they the only one that I feel that
is matured is Zelda like Zelda has
stepped up to me I will admit out of the
old ones that I do like Mario Kart is
mad funny
no Metroid yes that's right Metroid
Metroid Zelda Mario Kart out of their
old classic joints or if they do the
punch out it just seems like the only
thing he don't like is Mario yes
I'm tired of him I'm tired of him I'm
tired of him yeah absolutely right you
got me I am tired of him
I don't like like first party
Naper first yeah I don't like that I
don't like Pokemon I don't like the blue
dudes and all I don't like them I I just
did not for me it it to me I I when I
look at them games
Maddie got a joke for me like he'd be
like Cog why are you acting like you too
I'm like I feel like a creepy Uncle like
I shouldn't be playing those like I
shouldn't be touching those like I
should be away from the kids school plus
not for me first party give them crazy
yeah like oh I shouldn't be here sitting
Indian style with the kids like I should
beat it like it's not for me I'm not
this targeted yeah you know everybody
got these switches in the Indian style
their elbows touching to the kids and
you know that's what that is
I've never been in that setting
little balloon to say where this yo yo
they said they sent those Pax West
invites and he ripped them up
no no never respond no no see doc let me
let me break protocol because Don is
ripe called acting like Fire Emblem fire
mature updated zero cry with fire but
not abandoned action wear them games
that's what I was in I was like yes but
charity let's go he said they don't
exist anymore we know that detective Run
Deep I just want more of that in the new
stuff all the time they to me right now
in this digging in the crates old school
Uncle creepy bag and I'm not there with
it
uncle but anyway that was it but you
know they they the kings of the
capitalizing on the full moon they're
doing their thing regardless to my my
hate of those joints they're gonna sell
like Blockbusters they're gonna do
massive all I want is switch to and
let's go and let's get these Matrix five
demos and unreal all the mature stuff
that I want for you you know what's
crazy I don't know how
I became allies
Cog is the dude who invented the switch
coming in hot IMO yeah this is true in
fact I was a fan and I'm still a fan
yes I'm very addict world with Nintendo
it was it was a victory to get Cog back
in anyway thank you so if you know me
that was that was a victory just for me
to be a Nintendo guy in this era they're
my number one draft pick I told people
to switch is going to win that's gonna
be crazy yo shout out to dip down yes
it's white van energy with the yes yes
mystery mystery van energy we got candy
here energy
Nintendo fans in there I'm sorry I don't
look at you like like like like that
okay
exactly the energy you throwing out
right now
I just tell you as is a 40-something
that's how I feel watching their show I
shouldn't be at Chuck E cheese with
these kids I shouldn't beat it
was like oh man
I get uncomfortable
[Laughter]
that's that nasty day energy
here
[Applause]
so damn it Patrick I don't want you no
more
yo wow
go get in the closet all right I'm sorry
we're gonna get demonetized money too it
was over I apologize you know we have a
good relationship with y'all please the
thoughts of Cognito are one of his own
they do not represent I will put a
disclaimer or myself but
um so the uh the other show said yes
they move along
just just to clarify King we are
officially enemies again continue We Go
From First to worse let's hear this
Travis let's introduce this that same
day we got a September PlayStation state
of Play It Was a Good Day regardless
though yeah yes I there's some a lot of
stuff I didn't watch because I didn't
want to see just because I'm like I'm
like I don't want to see more Spider-Man
I'm done I just don't want to see him
so I I also don't have this one in order
but like I said so we got a release date
trailer for ff7 rebirth um that's the
game again I didn't finish I started the
original
we're holding on at least
that uh after three months uh other
platforms it may change the New Boston
Town his name is Reggie Hammond
you got a whole new seal over there and
money ain't acting right buckles over
there to get this break yo he said he
said yo who who who was blocking the
cash flow over here yo since when a
third party is acting like a first party
we are a third party yeah that means we
get three streams of Revenue yes so why
are we getting one uh-oh who did that
that dude he gotta go we back in
business we give them news three months
that's where the three comes funny the
third party the third party publisher
you get three months King has such a
good argument on that one he does
Microsoft don't really do second party
deals anymore so he could he could
comfortably fight on that Battlefield
with no resistance
that's what further dropped the show
down
you see sir
all right then right after let's see
what do we have
then we got Spiderman we got another uh
sort of trailer for Spider-Man looking
very good in the uh
yeah energy digital deluxe version uh
announced and kind of uh explained as to
what you're going to be getting some
stuff
10 what 10 costumes you can't get
through gameplay right so you gotta wait
for that
I did not want to see any of that I
understand blind on Spider-Man I don't
want to see it I don't want especially
because they do a lot of story stuff bro
I'm like why I showed me some story I
don't want to see that
um then we got that we got DLC for re4
uh which is called the separate ways DLC
is it a Wong is that one of the biggest
like games
like isn't that like humongous it wasn't
like the number one song
that's coming to the plantastic that's
crazy you know maybe it might reignite
some interest that's crazy you know you
know what's crazy you know what's crazy
one of the biggest things we all say
Microsoft needs to put on their stage is
Splinter Cell it never went isn't that
funny yeah what happened like Splinter
Cell is do they own that I mean I
thought it came out on their platform
exclusively at one point but you where
is that it came out of this show
because I thought we were talking about
the PlayStation
you want some mythical nonsense
for those of us who's a PlayStation vr2s
have been collecting dust which is funny
uh speaking of said piece of uh Hardware
that I was messing around with yesterday
a certain other piece of Hardware got
displaced as a result of that other
piece of Hardware I have to figure out
where to put it now uh yeah so closet
for those of us
psvr twos we'll be getting the re4
Remake PlayStation VR 2 mode which is
coming this winter
um yeah that's cool yeah that's cool
yeah for those people that's paid 700
you gotta uh you got a pony up thirty
dollars more it costs to be the boss at
least sometimes out here when you're the
number one you're the number one hey you
get people to lay down and buy forever
ain't too many more bosses
[Music]
we got another new trailer for Avatar
frontiers of Pandora oh man that look
dope that's dope it's for the streets
tonight
walking in the marketing you get to see
it on the biggest castle base first
hey you might not see it anywhere else
but you can see it there if you close
your eyes and don't look across the
street hey you don't see it over there
hey you you might not know what comes
out for any other platforms if you ain't
know any better that's that marketing
the rapper will tell me where's that hey
hey some people as intelligent as the
Lords to figure that out
some people thought Hogwarts Legacy
wasn't exclusive the way they told it
hey
surprise marketing is something else boy
it's kind of crazy when you spend money
just to make somebody else important hey
with your pockets are you know number
one you can do it you know what they're
gonna Market too right Call of Duty
with that logic
why buy Call of Duty
if we're buying Call of Duty if you're
going to be keep it for everyone why
even get Call of Duty yeah I'm not
buying Call of Duty games
I can't wait to rip my wings off
come from the Earth
you can't say nothing about them doing
ever it seems like every other week
yo listen hey man hey
listen I am not saying nothing about
this stuff over there yeah this is the
show That was supposed to be the show
this was a secret show
this one you worry about bad boys on
Twitter back they held it back for this
show this was the show because remember
the show is you that show was stinky it
was trash we know damn well they don't
got no real inside
these guys talking about this this is
the secret show so guess what I got a
secret for you it was a fault
oh
[Music]
Sony to bring the games
somebody forgot the password and they
couldn't let the other games in
you so what's the password is that a
Horizon forbidden West what's the rest
of that cool teach yourself
that we have uh up next to show opener
baby steps by Bennett's body which look
like it felt like I mean it it was a
weird indie game that looked like you
were like controlling somebody who's
like a zombie it doesn't know it doesn't
realize it doesn't know it
um that was first party I think it's
second party it was like a second part
again
that's what we got to look forward to
for sorry
[Laughter]
the man with the butterfly knees he was
doing the books
he had a wet diaper
yeah
yeah exactly
the whole outfit oh man without a crazy
remember
yeah you definitely look like that yeah
man you don't get a chance to run from
this one wait a second they started the
show somebody said put that first
for that alone everybody should have got
up and walked away
here you go there we go then we got
Roblox finally making his way to
PlayStation huge PlayStation bending the
knee the cross-platform
and that that was exclusive formally
intrusive you can play it on your rock
too we used to be able to play it only
on Xbox but yeah I go to the number one
platform
[Music]
install base to change things that's
nice Roblox is cool
cool is that one of the points that you
gave me yeah oh yeah absolutely
absolutely one of the points
then we have another game for us psvr
two owners to pull out the the old psvr
and dust it off Ghostbusters rise of the
ghost Lord is out next month psvr two
looking very nice if you like uh
Ghostbusters is like a perfect fit right
for VR
um yeah it feels like they're picking up
a little bit a little bit it's not first
party stuff though but at least it's a
little bit because uh we all know that
down the pipeline there's a certain uh
something something three coming out
that uh might eat his lunch
then we have hell divers too yeah
one second uh the sequel to a game that
was formerly I think a video game if I
remember and it was kind of like top
down same kind of thing the hell diver
sort of Landing dropping down and
fighting enemies so it's now it's like
it's not a top-down shooter anymore it's
a third person shooter live service
looks cool live service again one of
their whatever 12 13 live service games
and this is second part 25 25 sir
25 I don't remember 25 but okay
uh in development I think like all of
them I thought it was 10 but okay
then we got the announcement of uh foam
Stars open Beta we had the pleasure of
seeing foam stars at Pax West that was
King's highlight right there he went in
that was the best game of the show
yeah I don't know if you guys have seen
But King at Pax West he was a huge fan
definitely me and coach would love
everything
you can see that video on Twitter you
can see all that and then we have a
strange one tales of arise this is
getting an expansion uh two years after
the original game came out so again
power to them but I don't know who's
gonna go back to play it but yeah
that's
the third party game
that's a third party game so that that's
pretty much it so again obviously ff7
remake and the um episode and the
Spider-Man stuff is obviously the
highlights here so yes okay and for me
because I kind of turn away yeah
I turned away because I didn't I said I
had the opportunity to do that since I
wasn't live with you guys reacting so I
was like I'm not watching it and I still
haven't watched it I don't want to see
any more Spider-Man oh rebirth and
rebirth like I said I fell off of
rebirth because again I didn't have time
I started playing it and I loved it and
on the first ff7 remake and then I I
couldn't be on my my PlayStation for a
long time so I was like I lost track of
that so
I still haven't purchased it on PC which
is where I'm ultimately gonna play it
and finish it right at some point so I
didn't want to see anything of of the
rebirth either so yeah the two things I
was most excited for that I like the
most are I don't want to see so yeah
state of pleasure
Final Fantasy is all I needed to see
that's all that's it so stood on you you
stood on your based on your um oh still
oh you're still on your eight still one
thing one thing that would say all I
needed to say fair enough King uh has
your of the last we spoke at the live
reaction you were at a strong three
remember oh you gave it a four oh wow
okay so you're up to a four so now that
you have a little bit more time to sit
and things to resonate is anything
change from from year four sir no I
almost dropped it down back to a three
after I watch that thing again
I'm back for you yeah they offend you
more the second time I write yo the 40
the 45 minutes of that show
yo when are you dudes gonna realize that
the house is on absolute fire like it's
on absolute
fire when you start off this show with
baby steps okay
this is your Secret Show imagine the
horror in your heart right because
there's a lot of these PlayStation dudes
out here and the horror in your heart
you said this is the secret show you
went through I told you it was coming in
September the secret show was here it
was supposed to be in August this is the
games that they didn't show this is the
games they held back Sony's not holding
back no more and they start off with
baby steps
your heart must have crumbled it must
have went right into your chest
it must have turned the size of a
mustard seed
and then you got some courage seeing a
game that you know that's coming out
that you saw already like four or five
times now now you're back on Spider-Man
again and you sitting there like oh man
new suits that I gotta pay for all they
showed you Spider-Man 4 was look at all
the suits that if you don't order the
date I
you ain't gonna get inside the game so
go all in now lock the dummy in now to
get the suits in before the last game he
was just able to play the game and get
the suits out now you got to pay for
these suits
and then Final Fantasy
now I thought Jeff talked about it but
we got a date so the dates are important
so this is where they got that too from
me oh wow I knew the game was coming
Jeff showed it already they showed more
of it and it's good they showed it on
their stage it was the highlight of the
show one game does not save a show
it just defines the show as this is what
everybody was looking for so if you're
delusional if you say Amen as a Sony fan
the house ain't on fire
and this show wasn't just mid
it's absolute mid-show we're gonna miss
it
would be a five or six more than your
score so that's big
no the reason why
it's it's it's a mid show but you didn't
give a mid score
that technically you would give a point
for you would give a point okay okay me
like Eric said I'm there for me I feel
like right respect for me being there
for me I saw two games that I'm
definitely walking away playing okay I'm
definitely walking away playing
Spider-Man which will probably be my
game of the year why because I'm gonna
probably love this story because I love
what they did and I can't well I can't
wait for the deal so your game of the
year can't give it up yeah
it's what I like so yeah though like so
that means it was the best so it'd be
that you just saw the best game yeah
they only get them they only get a point
for having your game of the year the
only one point only I see it would have
got two points it was the first time or
the second time I'm seeing it okay okay
so because they show over exposure yes
okay I got you you're over saturating it
and like so I'm saying story stuff man
and the only reason why I'm watching is
because I'm live because normally I
would have just said to hell with it
right and then you got the Final Fantasy
so two games that's the four points
right there
there was nothing else in there that I
said yo let's get busy nothing yeah in
Roblox none of that definitely not
Roblox there's the same way that you
feel like switch give you a creepy Uncle
how they give you Roblox and and
Minecraft do the same thing for me like
somebody said hey man let's go to
Minecraft and I'm not doing that I'm not
doing that with You Want To Build A
Snowman no I do not want to build a
snowman and that's not gonna happen and
I'm not playing Roblox and I'm not doing
Minecraft but God bless with those
things no that's look this is coming
from the dude that play fortnite so
don't pay me
it's your opinion you know it's it's
like addict said what it does for you
you know clearly he's you guys are Polar
Opposites because because he really
likes them yeah he loves Final Fantasy
oh he saw what he saw he good and for
you you're like yo over exposure listen
I'm messing with you because we just
didn't fight because we do what I love
languages but I understand your position
I completely understand like they didn't
really have nothing for you and the
stuff that they showed code you know for
you you're like yeah you Overexposed
that and I've already seen it like three
or four times and you're already
convinced already about Spider-Man and I
get that look you know I get it for the
people who are in the chat and everybody
agrees with King I'm not coming for
y'all you know what I'm saying like you
could say it's mid that's fine you know
for for me I struggle with the house is
burning because you have a game of the
year candidate coming out in a month and
you know what I know that's going to
sell like gangbusters like they already
buying plates controllers look now if
you want to say they're restaurant in
loyal Royals they they they're
overexposing because they don't have
anything else or anything's not ready
Fair can't fight you there because I've
never seen that from them where they
keep kind of showing a lot like Final
Fantasy 16 I felt was Overexposed like
two or three shows too much we got it it
looks good we're convinced I get that
Final Fantasy though I agree with addict
though it's just that it was still a lot
of uncertainty of when it was coming so
we even though Jeff got the joint we got
the they got the date and they showed
some of the most beloved things that
everybody had questions so I thought the
the trailer was fantastic of course
that's going to bias me like it's my
show it's my rating like so me I'm like
that's what I'm talking about that's
what I want so but to your point King
what I did that was interest that made
me question and we I know we're going to
transition into addicts topic with the
Tokyo game show is for the first time
since the first remake we now see the
mortality on the exclusivity date
and what is very interesting is it's
only three months from release of the
PlayStation one normally I'd have been
like okay if they'd have been like
Final Fantasy comes out you know
February 2024 and then it'd be like all
platforms won't get it until 2025 right
then you go okay but that does put a
question mark now especially for the
Xbox guy that already was waiting and it
was like what's going on now they could
be like well let's see what happened in
three months and let's see what happened
with this Tokyo game show that's
supposed to be next week the fact that
square put it in a double pack gas could
could indicate that maybe the
exclusivity thing could be truly ending
maybe right we shall see we shall see
anything
I will say that the oh I lose is like yo
don't get your HOSA the only reason why
lucious I'm entertaining it is because
again
to have and this is kind of bleeding
into Alex Tower I'm sorry with the Tokyo
games but to have this new CEO on stage
with Phil and them talking about Square
titles Square themselves saying that we
plan on putting stuff that was missed or
whatever whatever is interesting so
we'll see what happens but as far as
back to the show
um look they had to support VR they had
to at least show some stuff I think
Resident Evil is a huge game I think
that's going to do well for them I don't
know how well but it should it should be
improved improve them and then um what
was the other one I know Roblox you're
laughing at but I know it's a big game
whatever whatever look average show but
the two games that they did show I
thought showed extremely well and that's
pretty much what I got as far as all
their joint but uh anything else from
anybody on the uh state of plays and the
directs and all that other good stuff so
we'll see oh faces in he's like don't
get your hopes up it's easy hey we will
see we will see I will remember these
words if anything changes that day after
that when I go up in the Xbox so don't
cry like I said we will see it is very
interesting that's also anyway
Super Chat sir okay let me see the
Mississippi
we got some funny ones here oh we got
Nintendo audio Taco two dollars in the
chat Paper Mario the Thousand Year Door
is the best RPG remake of 2024.
then we got a stitch two dollars in the
chat Nintendo games play better on Steam
deck facts
that is true
now we got Robert Kelly two dollar Super
Chat burnout X Forza Horizon sounds like
a day one like okay when I said burnout
it's because the Nitro the nitrous and
stuff like that you're not crashing and
doing hot slow-motion none of that so
don't don't think it's that but it just
the way it felt it felt a little bit
like paradise
um but minus the the stuff that you
really love bird out for but it just
kind of felt that way that's it that was
in the nitrous stuff that's what I feel
a little feel yeah
and we got uh like lady and Master
Legend Master remember for 10 months
Lord silver why did Sony Open this show
featuring attic space down in them
sure you gotta relax
just playing bro love y'all keep it
rocking yeah
we got we got the taco ten dollars which
direct was a 6.5 out of 10 they were
high highs Paper Mario unicorn Overlord
and low lows the switch is winding down
it seems like the PS5 is also winding
down the way they light up the look at
it
he's agreed with kids Jesus Christ
[Music]
Xenoblade Chronicles Bayonetta and
National Train don't exist anymore we
know that Nintendo hate runs deep
you know what type of Gamers what have
you done for me lately you know I like
but you're a Nintendo
gotta drink my my turmeric tea you could
get your tongue
then we got country big 94. Super Chat
yo what yo you got the black phone is
about uh uh a child murderer that he he
snatches up kids and puts them it was a
good night man yeah that was a great
movie oh he has this mask he comes out
with black balloons
yeah I'll be feeling weird with this
sort of days sometimes I'm just I'm just
it's not my I'm back to Target
then we have that Lazio Taco remember
for one month Lord bronze [__] talking
about creepy man energy but we'll play
Halo or cod with little Jimmy on his
team throwing out all types of language
yeah okay hey but we shooting guns it's
real out here it's real outside we
already played with our with friends
we're friends and like that's the
parents fault for letting little Timmy
get on that that's not my fault he not
this this is an adult playground
for those guys
then we got Phase 23 BK what twenty
dollar Super Chat King Xbox needs to
give you options for the games like
PlayStation does 30 40 60 and a 120 VR
option for Spider-Man 2. it's a huge
open world game not one first party Sony
game is only 30 FPS with no options yeah
they've been better but yeah they give
you options too should I buy this crap
or should I don't
should I get games for peripheral that I
don't need oh should I support a console
that I brought that yesterday y'all was
gonna support for five years but y'all
ditched me in the dirt when the first
game come out that hurt you guys stop
stop picking your little fake fights
just because Microsoft ain't doing it
over there you doing it over there y'all
need to have better choices when it
comes to day and day y'all should have
day and day why are you worrying about
what Microsoft is doing but you not
worrying about what y'all doing worry
about graphic options if you had a day
and day because you wouldn't care what
it looked like because it's free but she
you gotta sit there and point out yo
Microsoft need to give you I like the
options Microsoft gave me you can keep
your options in your verifle replay
straight with your TCL imma sit over
here and go play my games for free day
and day have fun with what you doing I'm
have fun with whatever
you're ridiculous
then we have six Slayer five dollar
Super Chat I thought baby steps was some
sort of meta joke not an actual game
first party Studio Sony Santa Monica
yeah that's good that's God award DLC
the plot twist
Target Chinese five dollars we'll just
have to wait for the super secret double
probation Sony show to get those real
game announcements any day now any day
now I don't know why y'all listen to
these fake insiders in October you'll be
clapping back at fake insiders to be if
it ain't Tom had just said I don't want
to hear it
this is true there we have lady Foxfire
five dollars if you chat I do only a
good snitch though
he leaked uh Final Fantasy rebirth being
at that State of play when he said he
said uh he said he said like a cryptic
like I can't wait to be rebirth or
something like that after I saw that I
was like okay so yeah it's clearly gonna
be there yeah he is a whole different
level of snitching with him
his name is the snitch
I just wanted to use the stitching over
today I get a chance to snitching over
won't you too much today
that we have a lady Foxfire five dollars
for chats morning good thing they showed
me was Spider-Man too but I'm still not
getting a PS5 for one game I'll wait for
PC love you guys thank you for all the
content thank you thank you blessing
they come out on PC in six months
then we got JD gamer ten dollars Super
Chat all right attic what do you think
happens if Microsoft buys square at that
point Microsoft will own more classic PS
PlayStation IPS than Sony does crash
spiral FF Etc they just need metal gear
solid and GTA Xbox will be more
PlayStation than Sony is if they bought
Square Enix they wouldn't they wouldn't
need those other things yep
then we got the doctor 63 5.
if Final Fantasy VII rebirth comes to
series X I'm throwing my PS5
you're gonna throw it when it's on fire
you're gonna take the Wings off and
throw it in there I want to know how
you're gonna do it so when you post this
remember we're gonna screenshot this
we're gonna hold you to your word and I
want you to do it so make sure you hit
me on Twitter you throwing it in the
bushes now you're throwing in what I
would suggest is you wrap it up in
pillows and throw it in the bushes
because this ridiculous statement that
you make in the absolutes you can go
back and pick it up and put it right
back inside your room and play your game
isn't it sound like come in the Xbox
you're in trouble
then we got JD gamer five dollar Super
Chat baby steps dot dot dot baby steps
what the f is wrong with Sony they have
lost all of their magic and their minds
triple games nah
this is
salute
[Music]
then we got puckish Rogue 105 Super Chat
you know just beat MK One damn another
wrong damn another great story mode oh
he was Blazing blazing that's crazy yeah
salute
then we have Nature Boy 80 five dollars
for chat Hey where's the dates for
hellblade two in favor we've seen
in-game cinematics but no dates isn't it
just announced the gameplay for the
first
when they gotta break somebody back
that's coming out early yeah hell play
too we should get that release date so
yeah we got um
the doctor 63 five dollar Super Chat in
relation to his post about throwing his
place I'll post a picture of it in the
bushes straight up oh so the challenge
King
got the bushes ready and then I want you
to post another picture with you taking
the leaves off of it and put it right
back
[Laughter]
don't be getting fly for the gram
[Music]
all right no doubt attic this is you you
can set it up set it up Xbox Tokyo game
show a lot of anticipation looks like in
uh the digital broadcast will return
called Xbox wire on September 21st so a
few more days and uh 6 p.m Japan time 9
9 A.M UTC 2 A.M Pacific and it says
Tokyo game show represents a special
time each year we shared news and
updates on games we hope will Delight
fans in Japan and across Asia players
can expect to hear updates from Xbox and
Bethesda and see a creatively diverse
collection of games from creatives
predominantly located in Japan and
across Asia also there seems to be some
anticipation uh Phil Dominus Maximus
Aurelia Spencer is outside we got a
welcoming message
um kind of promoting and teasing about
the show saying that um the future of
Xbox in Japan is bright hinting that
fans of Japanese titles have a lot to
look forward on Xbox platforms he said
we're thrilled to be back at the Tokyo's
game show this year with an Xbox digital
broadcast we invite players in Japan
around the world to the Xbox social
channels talk about the diverse lineup
of games it's how the future is bright
we can't wait to share these updates
from you and team Xbox and then I
believe the last thing you know there's
rumors obviously is about you know who's
going to be there and and that kind of
stuff as far as like presence and stuff
like that so um some as far as overall
not just Xbox some of the industry
Giants uh participated in the event
include Bandai Namco Capcom Kojima
Productions Konami Square Enix
PlayStation Nintendo and Xbox so it's
going to be a lot of you know people
there so what do you think this is your
topic Xbox Tokyo game show
first off we are with 700 people in the
chat hit that like that just get that
like button what animal movies we gotta
say some rare animals we'll be saving
y'all we'll save the PlayStation
leave it to him let's save the Sony show
s
if you say that they're not they're not
gonna like the puck oh man let's all get
together put our prayers together
this is my life support messy bro you
messy continue
um I think that
this is one of normally when when these
events happen I'm just like it is what
it is like I don't really
expect too much from them but I think
the reason that this particular TGs is a
little bit different than you know your
average TGs is I I think that there's
going
with this whole thing going on with
you know um
placed uh with a Xbox and Square Enix
like kind of mending whatever
relationship was damaged and we've seen
14 coming to the platform
I feel like we might see some Square
Enix stuff come to Xbox because this
would be the perfect time to show it you
know it I think it would be a good time
you know if Final Fantasy VII remake
ever comes to the platform it would be
at this event I I would say yeah
implying that the relationship may have
improved enough to have an announcement
at TGs from Square
I mean I I think because here's another
thing we have heard rumors that
the switch to prototype was running
Final Fantasy 7 remake oh so if that's
true
why
oh
platforms plural for the street streets
it was it was running at the uh Final
Fantasy 7 remake so if that's the case
clearly the game can be on other
platforms
so it's either PlayStation has like just
paid them not to keep it on Xbox and
there's a possibility that happened
but I think
Pros uh you know the the most likely
scenario is
scoring just didn't put it on the
console right it's just like look we
made the money you know there's not a
good relationship between us and
Microsoft why do it uh so would be
interesting is
we get remake you know be crazy if next
Thursday they Shadow drop remake in the
in the in the game pass yeah
and then three months after rebirth
comes out rebirth comes out makes you
messy but could they though because
isn't remake wasn't that part of that I
don't know the exclusivities are so
weird and so hard to understand if it's
a Trilogy it's individual with the with
the Remake games I mean here's my thing
if they were running Final Fantasy 7
remake
on the Xbox plot on the the switch to
prototype then clearly it's not like a
true exclusivity because to me you
wouldn't even you wouldn't even maintain
putting it on there if you couldn't do
it so it we'll see we'll see but would
be crazy is that they announced remake
coming to Xbox next week and then on
Twitter
switch is a now uh well Nintendo I don't
know maybe they could fit it on the
switch to like uh like um uh streaming
platform or something like that but I
think there's a chance I do you know I
would say there's like a 30 chance that
happens interesting um but I think the
biggest thing is just like if this does
happen you know we could we could be
completely wrong in in seven remake
doesn't get announced but they announced
Final Fantasy 9 remake on the Xbox
platform uh it's just I think something
like that has to be done
and this this new CEO clearly like he's
running things different yes so it's
just like I'm curious
if the difference is is my predecessors
believed in taking a big bag up front
but I think we can grow that back
throughout time on all platforms so I
wouldn't be surprised if you start
seeing you know the Final Fantasy 6 deal
16 deals you know the Final Fantasy
remake deals like that's gone and and to
be honest with you
it's like you said they were very clear
about that you know because remember
when when um Final Fantasy 7 remake
happened they took the original trailer
down and replaced it replaced it they
didn't do that they're like look it's
three months yeah but what's funny is
they didn't specifically say what
platforms like look it's not gonna
happen I would say 30 chances happens
but best case scenario for Xbox fans is
we get remake sometime at the end of
this year and we get rebirth sometimes
in the middle of next year like imagine
first off King
me and you that day if that happens
oh we we got to go we we got to do the
beer to podcast one and only episode the
one and done episode yeah because uh I'm
a I'ma lose my stuff I know y'all will
be super messy because because if remake
if remake does get announced I think
that
that opens the door for rebirth because
that means okay that means maybe not
next six months after next year maybe
the uh you know the time exclusivity's
like yo you could put it on other
platforms but not Xbox so maybe that's
going on but it to me I think there's
something happened
right and now that that's been fixed and
I'm curious
what we can what Xbox can get from
scoring style since clear this new CEO
really wants to to uh you know to
publish stuff and keep in mind when when
he came out and Phil was very clear
about this on that Dustin interview like
I don't want to say he's like I want you
to really highlight he said they're more
kinds not me yeah he said that Phil made
it a point to say that it was them that
said that yeah and it
look have they promoted that they're
going to TGs yes multiple years this
year feels different like this this year
doesn't feel this year feels like they
have something up they sleeve and they
know it I've been asked by people in the
industry and I can't go into who I had
to what they want me to react to it whoa
but I ca I'm not doing that because it's
like two in the morning
Grace would kill me if I stay there
yeah no I can't I could use the Mortal
Kombat excuse once all right so it's
just I'm interested you know if it
doesn't happen it doesn't happen but to
me
they've been getting real my dream with
Xbox is they have enough IPS enough
diversity and genres where they start
announcing stuff not necessarily how big
and captivating news it has but they
started announcing stuff where it makes
sense you got the Japanese stuff we're
gonna announce at a TGs you got you know
Forza stuff we're gonna announce that
you know between uh America and Europe
because Europe really really liked
racing and then it to me that's where it
is where it's like we're not putting
everything in E3 we're spreading it
throughout everything because some
places in the world there's going to be
games that hit more than other places
yeah now they have a lineup of titles
solve Tokyo game show your thoughts what
to expect how you feeling you think they
tease it you think they cook it
yeah I think
I think definitely teasing right I mean
the fact that they're making a point to
be out there feel coming out with like
sort of like a preview video being
excited to be there if they didn't have
anything that they felt was going to be
a semi big announcement at least
wouldn't do all that he wouldn't do all
that he'd appear like he did before
appear on stage and whatever and you'll
probably still do something like that in
surprise but you know I still think you
know there's a number of different
things right the Square Enix angle is
definitely there and the fact that we've
heard all these other things about how
you know the exclusivity windows are
much shorter for these upcoming Final
Fantasy games huh it would definitely be
a coup for ff9 to come like addict said
or uh you know another brand new IP it'd
be nice if they they announced octopath
too
I think that that is definitely I think
the least we'll get is an octopath
traveler 2 the most would be a 70
whatever yeah you know you don't be
crazy ones that they do like a Tomb
Raider where they're like
okay Xboxes we screwed you on Tomb
Raider announcing that exclusivity what
we'll do is well now it's remake and
we'll just tell them Reapers coming
after the exclusivity is that's crazy
exactly and then we have you know beyond
that we have you know we still have the
the atlas connection right the atlas
connection right we have uh we know that
Persona 3 uh reload is coming right to
to uh Game Pass tactical also tactic is
coming as well and then we have metaphor
refund Casio oh yeah
exactly so that you know we can
definitely hear more about that in
addition to the ones that they announced
if they do it things would be nice
yeah get them ready for shipping
I will do that but again yeah I mean
it's about time for them to start they
should be talking about the next Persona
and and I think one of the things they
needed first things is like hey it was
going you know you're cozy with Xbox is
it gonna happen is it not gonna happen I
don't think they let that question
linger too long they they gonna answer
that question pretty early I think
um and if you know if Phil had those
talks and dropped a bag off on day one
game pass or something like that it's a
lot of money I mean what according to
King's next topic squares financials
we're gonna have to talk about that too
exactly so you never know man maybe
maybe the bag isn't is not as big as we
expected
um so that it just feels like it feels
like they do have something to say right
right in addition to the fact that they
have you know at least their one of
their own Studios there right and we had
Hi-Fi Rush maybe we see what the next
big game coming out of that studio is
right so there's there's a lot to be
said there's a lot to be said and again
if Phil really wants to stay true to his
words about hey this exciting thing is
going on in Japan though those
announcements have to keep coming
whether the smaller games and and
finally getting access to larger games
that have traditionally been you know
PlayStation exclusives or time exclusive
or whatever the idea is to continue to
get that parody where you know hey this
all these games coming out day and date
on Xbox as well in addition to hey we've
been able to broker this other new thing
right for Game Pass or Xbox Etc so for
him to come out have that video it does
feel like they have something and they
have something how big of an
announcement that's gonna be the
question right yeah but you know but
Phil's pills you know Phil has a poker
face so we have no it could be the
biggest thing ever and he's not saying
it truth no good point about setting up
a that what is it that pre-record you
know thing to welcome and you know
that's a good point that it yeah and
think about it like that from a ponocial
standpoint did they do it for Gamescom
they didn't really do it for games they
don't remember them doing that for
Gamescom I remember like an Xbox wire
plus but I don't remember like Phil you
know recording a video talking and
speaking in you know yeah starting out
speaking Japanese yeah they really you
know the dominance is outside with this
like with this you know yeah it's okay
man you know Phil's outside talking
about you know get you know they're
happy with Xbox in Japan and that
relationship and um what do you think
well should what should we expect that
Tokyo game show
well you know when um
one person don't want you Sony made
their uh packed up everything out of
Japan like Yo close this up Europe is
our spot
Microsoft said oh they don't want you
boo Land of the Rising Sun let's get it
done let's get together hand in hand
let's walk these streets together bill
out there took your game show hey man
we gonna be doing big things we got a
lot of stuff over here popping and we're
going to show respect the Japanese
culture and show all our games that are
Japanese inspired yeah at the Tokyo gay
show
that was uh the you know
it'll feel celebrate yourself sucker
it's about to get Reckless now you start
looking at the Tea Leaves right maybe it
don't be announced there right maybe
they announced
um
the Remake and the rebirth uh because
it's one package maybe they couldn't
just give you remake straight up and
they had to put in a different skew and
they had to wait for rebirth to show up
that's why you only got the three months
on the joint right so maybe it was
language in the contract that
they had to you know this game couldn't
come in that current form to an Xbox
platform but this is the way you go
around it we Sony dissociates your
foolish behind we give it to you first
go ahead man
and after you know February 28th uh it
go up to 120 something dollars but check
out it right now for 69.95 you guys have
a good time with it have fun y'all been
playing that game don't worry about it
more people gonna play it too we
everybody gonna enjoy this so you got
three months to have fun in them big
Xbox is gonna come inside your head
to have all your cookies everything and
then this is when the narrative is going
to turn into so what king so what that's
an old game but that's what the dad is
going to turn into we don't care so what
key it's old and we don't had our way
with it
and we're gonna teach you new things
so play that game newly it's gonna be
different the way we stream it the way
we gonna play it's gonna be different
you're gonna be mad cause we don't be
playing the game way better than y'all
but um
I love Xbox the Tokyo game show and I
love the confidence Xbox is exuding
especially on the hills of your joint
that you just dropped the other day like
it's like Phil look the [__] yo
um I want everybody to look out for us
at Tokyo case
we gonna be there so
um if you've been disappointed by shows
this year so say on the death row you
back on your whole the Line energy pulse
way they had to show that people didn't
like the Showcase and then Microsoft
came by so you said that they had to
stay in place so this bike itself come
on again with the with you okay all
right
I'll see what it smelled like after the
Tokyo case you'll see
if y'all out there Xing around
I can't now let's see I mean if you
finish I'll jump in quick oh yeah look I
do think something's cooking I think
they're being Coy I think something was
going on
um and again every time Tokyo game show
comes out for the last three years I'm
gonna stand on my Square I was laughed
at everyone was saying that you know why
they over there they're not going to do
anything they're Never Gonna Make You
Dead that's what was told to me and I
said look there's a significance to
having Phil and Sarah Bond shout out to
the queen you know what I'm saying to
have them physically there every year
making the connections putting in the
groundwork what I consider the
Grassroots to truly improve there is
value and we have to admit those last
two to three years every single time
there's been major announcements that
Nina Cooney's a dragon the the um Yakuza
stuff the the atlas stuff the person
like it keeps growing they are improving
that and now
like we said we knew about what that big
announcement you know like the joke was
like being King had it was a funny
little joke but it's like yo he's on
Phil Dominus on stage with your girl
so the visual of that they know what
they're doing when I say your girl I'm
meaning the new CEO of square there is
symbolism to that everything one thing I
will always give Phil he's extremely
calculated with what he presents like
the Shelf the thing you know I mean who
he's with and then again to solve's
point with doing a pre-announcement now
again maybe I'm going too far with the
Final Fantasy right now only because the
only only reservation I have is that
even though we know the exclusivity is
ending in May and the game comes out in
February my only thing to make me pump
the brakes just a little is
contractually they may not be able to
talk about it until May so maybe it is
coming but like a subsequent show or
like may come that comes around right
around E3 time right June you can say
hey now we could talk about it and now
here's our you know package deal
whatever so I want to see how that um
you know that plays out but I do agree
also so I think there's other stuff to
be had with square you know we may I
know we want the home run off the back I
mean attic we want that home run we want
the thing but what could be like you
said something realistic octopath too
right had no business mean it missing
the Xbox platform after part one debut
right also pixel remaster people were
flipping out like yo this is a little
joint like what's going on you know kind
of thing so I still think there's
opportunity for square I still think
now whether or not he comes out on
Xbox's stage and he's ready to actually
talk about conceptually what his XBox
exclusive game is right that could be a
win you know anything added to game I
thought they did good at the show
remember they had that Capcom game that
was exclusive that was beautiful looking
with the remember that Capcom exclusive
Japanese joint yeah they had like I
can't pronounce the name of that Atlas
game so but it was an exclusive jrpg
you know you can get more of that you
know maybe more stuff that we didn't
think from the back law gets added in
the game pass we know um the like a
dragon stuff is coming because you know
me and um attic we played I played um
The Man Who Lost His Name you know I
played Persona tactic which was amazing
right and addict remember what
controllers we was playing on what
branding Atlas was happy to promote yeah
and when I say like it was a it wasn't a
little bit of a branding like they had
branded Xbox series X controls yeah yeah
so I expect they they have something
it's just gonna be to what extent or
maybe something we just didn't even see
from Left Field it man had nothing to do
this maybe he had something we will see
but I am excited I'm proud of them to
continue to impress me with the
commitment to Japan and commitment to
game passing games being on the platform
this is super important and if they pull
off another big thing again I told
people this is a mass Civ year for Xbox
you can say what you want about you know
you know Starfield may not be for
everyone but you cannot deny the impact
you cannot deny High fire rush you
cannot deny Age of Empires because maybe
you don't care but that's one of the
biggest strategy games going you know
what I'm saying yeah you could say red
four is a blip fear but they still got
fours to come in right and they and now
if they announce something big here this
is a this is a big year for them and
this is the type of cadence that people
are expecting that we thought was going
to continue on from 2021 now it's
happening in 2023 because bethesda's in
lock steps so yeah and I don't know if
y'all saw a ghost by Tokyo just put up a
thing they just did six million as far
as on that game that's in Game Pass
that's oh Tango
what's up and Xbox has said y'all we
love what they're doing over there you
know and we're gonna beef them off right
yo look out for Tango Something's
Cooking I'm just curious to what it is
but I'm gonna tell you add it bro you
I'll have grown man tears if I see that
Final Fantasy I ain't gonna hold you it
may be a little early but if they
somehow pull it up man listen we'll find
out we'll find out next week next time
yeah absolutely so we'll see but I'm
proud of them I thought this was really
really cool but that's all I got
anything else for anybody else we good
so I'm good we got all right let me see
the chat yeah one okay we got ogtk cold
I just want to say Spider-Man 2 got the
Bronx down back they don't even mention
y'all Brooklyn pushes out out the
picture as usual oh can we do it happy
yeah it keeps on making him Brooklyn
keeps on taking it
um and and Brooklyn
um Staten Island
they talking yeah you know it's all of
Manhattan then queens and Brooklyn I
don't know how much of Queensland
Brooklyn is probably a small portion
it's probably a small portion
they'll want that they don't want that
smoking yeah with that VX mode
that's what always do it's too ready the
villain's over there
none of that stuff Uptown to the boogie
down you know what I'm saying you
definitely pack them up
you need Luke Cage
when you try to say Peter Parker don't
go down that way
he don't go fast
he get off at 96.
exactly
Uptown Smoke different
Dumbo right now he's in a different area
right now
don't play that New York different buddy
like the only the only superhero or hero
I see ever going to the BX computer
Punisher
is out of the Bronx right yeah
the work over there
he went down to Hell's Kitchen
yeah we were all for this one
Bronx villains and heroes is a little
bit
from
[Laughter]
yeah from 178.
all the brothers
all right we gotta stop we doing the
most we do it let's get this that was
the last thing we chat yeah that was it
oh man we got to say King up final topic
and then we out of here oh geez laughing
he said y'all can't make my day with
that one no no it's all all jokes are
fun so uh yeah this is um Square king
um per Bloomberg Final Fantasy I'll make
his face right now 30 uh making 30
plunge may just be the beginning Square
Enix is heavily reliant on hit series to
drive sales new CEO faces skepticism
about companies growth prospects so
let's get into it yeah there's a lot of
talk right now about
um squares so according to Takashi can't
I pronounce his last name I always
butcher it but um yeah they said you
know um Square had shed nearly 2 billion
of its value since um Final Fantasy 16
the latest installment that came out
with mixed reviews now investors wonder
whether or not one of the games
industry's most remarkable runs is
coming into an in so
um yeah they just said that as far as
the you know the sales they were
underwhelmed things got worse in August
for the company reported a sharp profit
because he left the class shares
plummeted by double digits a dozen
analysts tracking the stock cut their
price Target and long-term investor I
can't pronounce sumatumo mitsui trust
asset management company slashed its
Holdings in the games company and um
yeah it says Square Enix is on a streak
of misfires an attempt to build another
hit series to buttress sale it's fallen
behind Rivals Capcom Activision Blizzard
in terms of market value the car
the companies Fall From Grace offers
hard lessons for the industry about the
importance of quality control and
product planning and fans analysts and
developers who have done business or at
the studio they said they've been
flooding the market this is what um a
Tokyo based developer and gamer Michael
Prefontaine said that they've been
flooding Market with unfinished bad or
untested games as a bad move citing
Marvel Avengers for spoken and the the
deal field Chronicle as examples of
poorly thought out games the company has
overstretched itself on too many titles
without proper oversight Gamers have
come also complain about the mobile
titles I think it's all Bravely Default
and that goes of Mana
um current and former Square edix
employees asking not to be named pin the
blame for that on the company's approach
of making every game project a single
producer Fife them so basically saying
that producers are giving way too much
rain over the scope and direction
there's a shortage of proper
documentation and team structures
contractors who've done work for Square
Enix prescribe an ad hoc process where
project goals can shift without warning
High degree of volatility from the um
prop uh products um also they said you
know for spoken I'm reading the article
yeah this is not I'm not the ones that
they say such as multi-million dollar
flop for spoken has failed to find an
audience and um the final things is now
they have the new CEO Takashi uh Kiryu a
48 old guy
um he said he intends to whittle down
the number of smaller titles and this
decrease Outsourcing to focus on big
budget games with higher potential to
improve the company's profitability and
um yeah they they said that um this was
going to be right after the forespoken
you know they um they said they're going
to implement that um process so yeah
this is still more
stuff about the Metacritic this this is
a very long article in extreme detail I
highly represented go to bluebird.com
check this out you know there's a lot to
be said I'm trying to just you know
summarize as best I can because we'll be
here all day they still have more
affiliate they're kind of long-winded
you know yeah use them a lot you know oh
they're okay
fair enough this is legit news you know
we we only use the best
listen so kick this is your topic
clearly you have things to say you
wanted to talk about this what you
thought sir I thought these dudes was
doing well I I mean from what I had
heard I had heard that Final Fantasy was
a success and then um all they troubles
was behind them but apparently the the
series of missteps saying flops and and
thinking that they can only produce
games for One console when they're
multi-console uh distributor that's uh
put the the company in a bad position
now I brought this up because seeing
that thing in financial stress
you know is Microsoft one of those
lending companies that show up as soon
as they yo yo your credit score here the
certain marks yeah seems to be the trend
lately
[Applause]
out of curiosity I know I've asked this
before
I don't think I can describe the
Meltdown on Twitter if they bought
Square Enix like I don't think I could
no I'm not even I'm just talking about
buying them like
I don't think any of us know how bad
twitter will be
if that ever happened I don't think they
would even care anymore I mean they had
them
definitely caring I think they had the
thought process then but that's when
they probably thought they was a a
Soaring Eagle right now after forspoken
came out their wounded calf in the
middle of this field and they're like yo
we can fix you
we don't want you we just want your milk
um you're gonna hold them back there
partner all right and then you know they
make the deal with the devil they got
called for hey and I called Philadelphia
I'm just saying
you had a stance and The Stance was
clear for gamers you pick the side and
that side let you down
the side ain't there you know now now
reports is coming out that they were
fighting in the house
that it was mismanagement nobody was
doing the dirty laundry everything
everything is piling up in there it
ain't looking good and bills is backing
up and you ain't the square that we
thought you was so we don't really want
to purchase you well we do do like what
you do have and you you was nice back in
the days and we would like to purchase a
couple of memories that you have the
most to give the house people wait wait
are you implying that they made bad
decisions bad business practices by
siding and making timed exclusive deals
yeah
yeah that has been an albatross around
their neck if you look at it if they
would have just concentrated
like on the article said they they
spread themselves too thin all over the
place and uh went with Blockbuster games
that were they could they were able to
blame the Western Division Western
Division didn't do anything without two
directions so stop playing around you
saw the game you put the game out and
you needed to blame somebody for your
missteps and flubs right so your
missteps and flops got you in this
position now we know Avengers was
multiplied because Disney would not have
taken you just making it just for Sony
right but we also know the attentions
because you made Spider-Man a single
character on one platform he never
really said characters
right that was when old CEO was in
charge factual making uh
what I can only consider is tribalism uh
decisions
with a company
now this CEO is a realist we cannot
continue to do the same thing as
expecting different results that's the
definition of insanity so what we must
do is we must diversify we must fortify
we must remove the fluff so no more
we'll be doing the crazy uh uh games we
putting out all the time like uh
mismanaged games we're gonna focus on
traditional Square stuff go right back
to their normal Cadence when they
release a game every three to four years
there's high quality highly tested and
spread across the boards
I think you're going to start seeing the
fruits of that bear bear fruit because
you know Microsoft went over there and
asked yeah they're not gonna see you in
distress and just say yo we don't want
this they want that it's harder right
now to buy a company but it's easier to
break down those barriers that was there
I'm just saying this this is a good
thing for square day maybe they had to
hit rock bottom in order to know that
they have to be on Nintendo they have to
be on Sony and they have to be on Xbox
in order to get their company back to
the winning ways
yeah it's it's a strong argument not
hard to refute can't end stuff for this
one I mean obviously there's a lot of
financial data get it over to attic you
know you've got a lot of videos on
Square always historically you've always
been in the mix with a square videos and
stuff like that so when you hear about
this report from Bloomberg in reference
to like the financial troubles and them
really having to make a shift like
what's your thoughts on this
I think
there's clearly
they get a lot of it's just
self-sabotage like like you were eating
in that um article
you know some of their games didn't hit
the way they thought it would uh there
was that one game they made for an
exclusive on Playstation what was that
game
it did really bad
um
it wasn't for spoken it was something
else it was another one or maybe
platinum made that game no was it the um
it was the the what is the the
game as a service yeah
Marvel Avengers they pushed badass and
uh games as a service and they could
have went the guards of the Galaxy when
I think that game would have been mad
successful they lost I think it was
rumored they lost like 200 million 300
million just off of that just off of
that one game wow then you got babylon's
fall yeah uh you know
there has been many games that that were
underwhelming more quite like that game
yeah a lot of people didn't like that no
you're right and Marvel not to cut you
but Marvel Avengers you're right like
that was a huge they had big
anticipation for that game they thought
they had a live service in the joint
with the with the license yeah that's a
that was a big Financial loss I'm
talking to you then you got first spoken
you know it for spoken definitely in a
lot of ways uh I I I'm sure that game
didn't do the greatest like like
commercial wise because it kind of felt
like the end you someone else go these
cats
yeah so someone else go why uh
but uh solve your thoughts on it on the
uh you know the the reports from
Bloomberg on squares Financial issues
yeah I just think you know a lot of the
smaller games that they've been putting
out haven't hit the way they wanted them
to whether it was you know Tactics Ogre
or like the the world ends with you the
trials of Mana even live alive right
that still at this point has not come to
PC if I'm not mistaken right uh
collection of Mana things of that nature
it's just so the smaller stuff that
they've been investing time and effort
into it although seemingly quality games
still hasn't sold to where they would
sort of need it to sell and then when
they have come out with the bigger games
it just they haven't hit like they've
expected to like F of 16 could be a
great game on its own but it got pushed
back from the from the core base because
at the end of the day you can't take
risks it's very difficult to take risks
like that anymore especially with
unnumbered sequel in a final fan in the
Final Fantasy series like people are
expecting an RPG 16 should have been a
um a spin-off yeah 16 that game should
not have been a numbered game right it's
a great I think they were very worried
they couldn't sell it if it wasn't
another game though yeah and that's
that's very strange because I I don't
know how um stranger Paradise did right
but that was very clearly a spin-off oh
God forgot about right game that game
didn't do well either at all but you
know by all accounts people who played
it thought it was cool like the combat
was cool whatever and it was this
reimagining of Final Fantasy one which
is obviously was an RPG but a much more
simple RPG than what we used to them now
right so you take that you turn it into
an action game cool
um
so they could do things like that but
when it comes to they have to deliver
with their big franchises in the way
that their fans expect uh and part of
that expectation is the type of games
they expect and this is that fair no
right I'm I'm the dude that says do
whatever you want to do but at the end
of the day the fan base is going to
speak
and obviously overall this game did not
do what it needed to do to make back its
money and you know now contributing to a
two billion dollar loss so that is to me
yeah if it kind of and part of that
right go back to the new CEO it's this
idea that you cannot survive
throwing you know Nintendo a bone here
and there and then putting everything
only on Playstation you have to address
the entire gaming ecosystem the entire
space I can see a lot of these games
coming out PC day and days even if they
skipped Xbox
PC by itself yeah
ff7 remake day one on PC yeah would have
would have been crazy
so it to me I bet you that new CEO
punching the uh the the air too man I
gotta deal with these PlayStations
exclusive yeah because because he told
he's talking about spreading the wealth
and put putting those games out there if
you have a Tactics Ogre which I don't
remember if that was David it wasn't on
PC it wasn't on Xbox it was right so
things like that like I beat that game
too you have to do everything you have
that's a tough game too
um you have to do everything you have to
you can to make these games try to
survive but then there was a moment also
they were doing a lot of the Farming
Simulator at the same time the dial
field Chronicles and stuff like that
when it comes to all these games that
are kind of sort of similar to one
another and not they don't stand out in
any real way back in the day when you
got a game from Square Enix it was
something it was it was an event whether
it was a Final Fantasy game whether it
was
um uh Whatchamacallit what was the other
one the with the Xeno gears game Dragon
Quest Dragon Quest right they also have
Dragon Quest which to me now with this
next one I think they're going a little
more mature right which I think makes
sense finally to bring Dragon Quest a
little bit forward and and and kind of
Make it try to make it more appealing to
a broader audience so all of these
things are things that they have to do
to sort of bring back that name and then
Focus you know with your smaller games
less of an investment bring back some of
these old franchises to see what the
interest is and and work that way and
work that way but again this idea that
you know which really surprised me this
idea that all of these producers kind of
had it
do whatever they want to do I'm like
what the hell it it really doesn't feel
like that was that's not a square thing
like that to me it didn't feel like that
was part of their culture but apparently
that's where they are right now so yeah
they just need to tighten the purse
Rings tighten the belt Focus uh give
people what they want even if that means
not being not as creative as maybe as
you'd like to be to sort of get the you
know back into good graces of people I
know you know again Final Fantasy uh you
know seven rebirth will immediately
bring a lot of people right back right
because that's feels like a product that
you know they're putting the love and
effort and Care into making it what the
fans want especially with the
expectations I have to remake yeah so
it's it's refocusing on that stuff
getting back the name getting back
getting the the bottom line back to
where it needs to be and in the black
because a two billion dollar loss it's
almost unfathomable to me that they
would lose that much money but it goes
back to our friend Sean Laden
these games are getting too out of hand
they're not sustainable and when you
have and we saw it with square in we saw
it with them and and and Crystal
Dynamics and all these expectations of
all these of these games that you know
when you talk about Avengers when you
talk about
um what the heck was the other series
that didn't meet expectations uh
Guardians of the Galaxy yeah I forgot
about that one like the it so that's
what I'm saying it puts good games in a
position where they have to perform like
they are
super duper like quadruple a world
Killer games and they're just not that
so it's not enough for these games to
sell five million copies this is not
enough
um so yeah they got they got to fix
things I I think this guy has the right
idea not locking out Xbox and kind of
trying to be more ubiquitous and
hopefully also uh opening up more to the
PC space day and date with the bigger
games yeah I think I think will help
them immensely yeah no I agree I'll jump
in um you know
this was this was surprising it was more
that I left out that King is probably I
forgot you know they said that the
company released a new the new mobile
Final Fantasy 7 again me and addict got
a chance to see that game right um the
Final Fantasy moment we thought it
looked good right when we saw it at Pax
West but um it said but they released it
last week but sales already fell short
of investor expectation Square Enix
stock have lost about 30 from its peak
this year and on Wednesday was on track
to close at its lowest since May last
year then they said rebuilding the story
maker of role-playing games would take
years and there's little hope this is
what security analysts are saying of
upside potential on earnings in the near
term the company has rested on its
Laurels for too long and may have
already exhausted the patience of loyal
friends who are growing tired of seeing
old games I'm right there reissued yep
on mobile platforms he said the failure
for square to make a third major
franchise that is not named Final
Fantasy and Dragon Quest is the key to
this skepticism they said if we look
five years ahead there isn't much that
can make investors confident about the
company's future
whoa that's crazy oh here's the thing
right when you hang out with Sony
exclusively here's the thing you know I
think Final Fantasy 16 is the biggest
70s that's an 87 I've ever seen in my
life so it's like look I get it you you
made everything look pretty so people
gravitated towards it but it doesn't
take away the fact that uh the game
wasn't a Final Fantasy game it didn't
have the core elements of a Final
Fantasy game whoever greenlit that game
and it's like like it's just little
things like in every Final Fantasy you
know the there's Elemental things called
um uh they're called Fireballs or bombs
some people uh some games so it's pretty
much like a it's a bomb that grows when
you hit it it's like a now naturally in
older final fantasies when you hit them
with fire they absorb it because they're
fired but what happen
in 16 they didn't care about that you
can hit him with fire he takes damage
there was no Elemental damage whatsoever
in that game Elementary and it's just
like and you have you have summons that
are Elemental but there's Elemental
damage and it's just like whoever agreed
it's just look scoring Enix is just
beyond Square Enix is in the position
they are from Bad uh business moves such
as locking a lot of their games behind
timed exclusivities to full-blown
exclusivities uh quality control because
they like games like for spoken came out
that it kind of seemed like three or
four different games that didn't really
know what it wanted to do half the game
uh you got games like um
with that game that we just said and I
forgot its name all remake what is it a
pixel was a no the game that we just
said so you just said it uh stranger
Paradise that game too uh
I people said it's the Stark Souls of
Final Fantasy no it's not
and then there's the other game that we
were talking about that real it was the
games of the service did not do very
well at all uh
something babylon's fall babylon's fall
then you got you know decisions on
trying to you know
just put it to you in the perspective
this way Marvel Avengers was out
almost the height
of the Marvel Universe no and it still
didn't do successful it's just like look
make better games that's that's the
better thing I could have make better
games yeah you know 16 doesn't there's a
reason that you see people like me
stepping away I'm done with final
fantasies that are newer games I'm done
with 17 18 19 20 whatever they want to
call from here on out like I'm done with
those games because 16 was my last straw
16 did not feel like a Final Fantasy
game it felt like a very action-paced
game that just so happened it's like
we're gonna make a Devil May Cry type of
game but we're just gonna use summons to
really amp it up and I was attacked
because I said I was concerned with how
focused the summons were in every
trailer and that's literally the game
focus is on the open attic the summon
fights are cool yeah they're qte fights
essentially you move left to right you
attack left to right attack that's
literally almost every one of them I did
it's a look greatness is the way they is
because of them and I feel like they'll
they'll they'll pivot you know but are
they gonna pivot correctly maybe the new
CEO get is enough good blood to be like
look like
we need to really correct or we're done
yeah and and I don't know because here's
the thing I honestly think if
I don't think no one's trying to buy
them
um I really don't I it's all it's clear
like timson's never tried to buy them
tinted don't even own stock in them does
do they I don't know I don't know it's
an old stock and everything
I don't know
yeah someone in the chat correct me if
they own stock in them but even if they
do uh score as Sony nothing uh Xbox you
know they don't even come out on their
game so it's like you
I have more sympathy for people that do
everything in their power but still fell
then
we're gonna go into the mobile market
okay we're not going to the mobile
market we're going to make conso games
okay we're not going to make consoles
we're making live service games okay
we're not making live service games
we'll focus on Final Fantasy okay we're
not focused on Final Fantasy we're gonna
do something different Final Fantasy
okay we're not working on some different
Final Fantasy we're going back to mobile
like
stick to a core expand the core and stop
jumping around the way you're doing
because you you're sitting here trying
to have your hand in every cookie jar
but you're not getting any cookies
yeah we gotta see what's gonna happen
man I didn't realize like I said you
know reading that article and it's con
entirety like how tiredness yeah it is
it is this is a k n exclusive yeah I
gotta give them that you know what I'm
saying like I didn't I didn't because
they used to be one of the the dominance
yeah I don't want them to go away and
this is why damn homie man lights
happening to you so yeah like you know I
remember them you know this is one of
the main reasons why I fell in love with
PlayStation one I remember seeing Final
Fantasy VII and kind of you know say
what you will you know popularizing the
Jr RPG band for you know that so I've
said you know casuals and people who you
know you would never really gave the
genre a shot so you know I think yeah
they're in trouble there's no mistake
now I will say that I do like the fact
that yeah there's a new CEO and they're
looking to that's and especially the way
they were talking to Microsoft that's a
really good sign because they're being
more open to business than they are
right and and to me look I know a lot of
people say Hey you know just because you
know you guys you have a preference for
Xbox or something like that just because
it's on Xbox It's Gonna Save it but
here's the reality it's not just that
it's all I used to have this
conversation with Maddie when I was
annoyed with them and I'm like I used to
just say Square make it make sense you
would just isolate whole platforms
exclusive with one platform and it would
make it would make no sense especially
the octopath situate that drove me
actually because the original put out
the secret yeah this PlayStation don't
get the sequel but they don't get the
original yeah but they get this they get
the sequel and then it's like oh you
know Final Fantasy remake is all
PlayStation exclusive but then you
giving Xbox Crisis Core
so it would just I would just like make
it mix it like to me this is when
it's like they were acting like
mercenaries with Check to Check energy
you got that I'm living tractor you know
that check to check dude you know that
dude we know he like yo bro and it's
just you just good for this week and you
don't know how it's gonna go next week
so you just gonna you're gonna rock out
or whoever's there that week you know
what I'm saying that's gonna get you the
cab money in a sandwich or whatever it
is that you need and I think to get
through your work day like yeah I think
it hit so hard with me because like I
really want Final Fantasy be back where
it was absolutely I really want Dragon
Quest to because I Dragon Quest 11 was a
solid experience yeah and it's just like
if this company goes under under right
it's some of the most iconic franchises
just gone right like obviously they
would sell off but yeah it's just like
it's gonna be different yeah I just hate
the segmentation and the way they handle
things they were just all over the place
so you yeah like I think you know that
the um you know new CEO and I I agree
with King the timing is quite
interesting that all of a sudden you out
there saying hey we're gonna put this
out there on Xbox and other platforms
because yo sometimes you know that check
to check and you look at what's going on
and you got to make changes you can't
live how you've been living you know
what I'm saying so that's that I think
that to me it's bigger it's it's Xbox
PC and switch if you drop them at the
same time and like what is it attic you
said they were the rumors of Final
Fantasy 7 remake being you know on the
new Switch oh sorry nine but what
whatever seven it was seven you know
what's crazy triangle strategy and I'm
pretty sure that was a square unit yes
that was a phenomenal game amazing and
it was only on switch and by the time
because timing is everything yep guys by
the time the people that was interested
in that kind of gameplay they already
moved on if that would have dropped on
Xbox PlayStation switch and PC at the
same time the sales probably would have
doubled exactly so this is where taking
that like king would say like that
little small money ain't really do it
for y'all so look it is what it is we'll
see what's going on I do I agree with
doosov though the thing that was the
biggest concern for me is hearing about
the volatility in the studios and the
producers you know running around like
five thumbs and they too much controls
and all organization and documentation
problems and like that really surprised
me I didn't know they were having all
these internal problems with Dev teams
and that that that's that's a little
spooky you know I do disagree with that
dude that said that he feels like they
needed a new IP look they do need to
work on that I think Kingdom Hearts he
didn't bring up Kingdom Hearts was it
interesting that's like a huge franchise
for them I would say that was the third
one but maybe the reason to do that is
because that that's an existing thing
from Disney and Final Fantasy together
but it's just like no like the problem
is is they're they're they're they're
having very underperforming games when
it matters Marvel Avengers and any other
Pro I guarantee you give that project to
a lot of other Studios maybe Naughty Dog
they would have made that a hit run so
10 15 million for some reason Square
Enix chased the bag we see the fortnite
money the live service the war zone
money we want that money well guess what
that product didn't make sense in that
money right and you ended up paying the
price and it's just like that game it's
like we just named like five big AAA
games usually how how it's always been
and you guys can contest to this the big
games pay for the small games right the
problem is the big games aren't doing
yeah they're not doing what they're
doing and yeah you know they got the
number and clearly the when you know on
Twitter when it's like hey three million
for this and Final Fantasy 16 did this
clearly these are just appointments to
square this is the only thing they're
probably making money off of is Final
Fantasy 14. Final uh final Final Fantasy
VII uh it was multiple sources said that
they weren't like like 16 did money but
not as well as they would have wanted
right and
the the smaller projects because they're
probably making money but the problem is
there's not enough people are buying
those to justify everything else yeah so
it's those games that these people
aren't buying stuff right
they're not on Xbox that's for sure oh
okay
they should do this out here talking
about numbers and they are not
supporting right these numbers listen
bravery default to phenomenal game a
triangle strategy phenomenal game none
of those are on Xbox and they and they
dropped on a platform first before
anything else
that sucks yeah you gotta bring back man
yeah you'll see quiet man got to come
back hopefully the same square either I
had a quiet video
we're used to tobo number one and turbo
number two they really need to get a
turbo number three out the door
Panasonic he doesn't want to Outsource
as much I actually disagree if you want
to make something like the strangers of
paradise you should have contracted like
from software and actually give them the
IP to make a final fantasy Dark Souls
game like it's just like dude you're
trying you're trying to build stuff that
you don't have the tools for yeah it's a
lot of it's wave capturing too but look
we beat this thing to death all I would
say is if it does continue to get spooky
you know stay tuned I hope Sony and
Microsoft and I wonder if you know Phil
has the hooks in all right yeah if if
things go spooky after avk we know for
the record my extended warranty
Microsoft has claimed on the record
after ABK they are not done
and according to you know recent history
if you've been known to have financial
problems Microsoft is very keen to
swooping as your savior again I'm just
saying I know I know people hate without
they say I don't know the acquisition
I'm just telling you how Microsoft tends
to move when it comes to m a emergency
hey if you might be going through a
rough year and a rough months
and then he got his arm around you on
stage
Halo hey Big Head
the CEO goes like I said he's early
mentioned he does look like he actually
you know he's more in in the know than
it seemed like the previous gentleman in
Pocket yeah so he definitely looks like
you know because I think even if
Microsoft stepped in and bought them
after ABK until they get that management
fix that's right that's gonna flop too
right like that management needs to be
restructured to incorporate an actual
modern game or it could be like how even
let's just say the Sega thing you know
even though I want my heart I want Sega
but it could be a Sega situation where
it's just like hey we've got to develop
this partnership and now the Game Pass
back
yo what happened yo King keep telling me
it wouldn't be bad if they if they came
up with my that Microsoft gave them a
big big bag it was like all you games in
Game Pass game day I mean remember hold
on this ain't too out of the realm of
possibility remember when things were
going good with the old CEO there was a
period with all the Final Fantasy joints
was coming into Game Pass yeah and then
it went left for reasons we don't know
at the time you said
probably blaming them dudes like yo
we're in this financial trouble with a
view to purchased us that started
running over there and going to get
these dudes hey King remember right that
we saw the m a document Square was on it
it was the only one in there
if someone happened to get left at the
altar and here come ABK what's the mean
with the dude and then the girl wanted
to like to do with his girl right the
holy square and then he looking back and
then you see with the face
I guess to me it's like look we don't
know 100 what's going on in these
situations we only but I do trust Jason
schreier sources and if it is a lot of
like producer thing and the way the
company infrastructure is I want Square
Enix to be that that top dog because I
love that company but it's just like
every game they proved me right on just
doubting them and it's like I want to be
wrong with this company like it's like
when I made the bet with King you know
Xbox buy score Enix I don't think that's
gonna happen but I'm willing to get my
knees for that yeah yeah I know you are
anyway that's all I got anything else we
good we're gonna get up out of here
I have one believe in that new CEO he
has such a great smile really makes me
believe that he'll take Square to new
heights with octopath two on Xbox
I I I hope that that dude really puts
them back where they need to be yeah
hope so hope so no I never want anyone
to go away and that's why especially
scoring units yeah that would be even if
they come Sony disappear
even if they only working with them even
if they only work with like PlayStation
for the rest of gaming it's like I'd
rather have their games around than not
around no no no
if they still stick around if they only
answer so this whole argument is about
them having that mentality
you saw back to you we need to fix it oh
that was it I know that all right with
the latest Sony dupole with the latest
Sony state of playing Nintendo Direct
both making their reveals on the same
day this past week which show resonated
with you the most choices are a massive
Nintendo first party offerings third
party and titles releasing this year and
2024. B PlayStation game of the year
Contender Spider-Man 2 Final Fantasy 7
rebirth and pressing Sean with release
date plus commitment to psvr2 or see I
don't care about none of that let's see
what Xbox does at Tokyo game show that
is the choice please Rock the vote when
it goes up on is it Twitter or the X as
we call it these days that's all I got
Lord addict where can the fine people
find you what you got going on sir you
can follow me on Twitter at Lord addict
IOP uh you can find me on YouTube a
gaming addict I actually gonna make some
unique videos here soon
um because I do the news thing and I
liked it in the news but I want to do
more opinion pieces like variety of
opinion pieces because all my News
videos are opinion pieces I I I put them
in a nice little bowl for you guys you
know you know he ties out to spin that
stupid chair you guys don't understand
yeah so it's just I appreciate everyone
coming through you guys have really been
supporting that one thing I want to
bring up you know me and King uh you
know we've been talking really good
about how to make the patreon more fun
and more Community uh more Community
Based so you know I put in the the poll
as you guys could see it's it's three
hours ago I put it 741 people voted and
would you guys like Friday night uh
Friday night fight nights playing with
King uh with uh fight uh games with King
David and 81 of 741 people said yes
so you know what we're gonna do is we're
gonna start obviously this is gonna
happen now because we gotta actually sit
down and think how we're gonna do this
uh we're gonna start doing some uh some
community Tuesday night thing now how it
will go is my the way I would like it
done is we would stream that to like
maybe kick or twitch because uh we do
have someone that's like helping us
without the YouTube algorithm and he
says stuff like that's not necessarily
the best for us so I would like to do
that and
patreons and members will get you know
first dibs on being in those Community
nights you could watch it
but if you if if you want to you know
physically be king at Fighters like
you're gonna have to I mean King might
beat you we don't know we don't know uh
so we got some other stuff with the
fight nights that we want to do but as
of right now uh you know we'll figure
out a good date to start that uh so I
don't know when King wants to do that
maybe he wants to wait for Tekken I
don't know
Mortal Kombat then I can figure that out
and then you know about Street Fighter
Mortal Kombat a lot of you dudes like
was capping for some Killer Instinct you
just want me to just do some wild combos
on you would say but
um but um oh no it would be multiple
games people are asking what type of
games
King will be in charge of that you have
to talk to King about the Nintendo he
outside he says as long as your hop on
smash or Street Fighters
that's not a fight game bro damn it's
it's at Evo how you say it's not a fight
come on man
that's the energy I feel when Cox says
that when y'all talk about fighting
games and y'all pull that out I feel
like the creepy Uncle
get that game out of my hands I should
have a fluffy lump Kirby puff squeezing
and sucking people in and spitting them
out
I gotta play these fight nights playing
games I literally don't play ever you
can take all the challenges on with the
social security card God bless
old school we're gonna play Old School
we're going back man we're gonna play
towball number one
right there so definitely go sign up to
it now has been updated I'll probably
put it uh you know find a tear to put it
in but I think it'll be fun you know
we'll we'll stream it to the whole
Community but if you want in on them
sticks you know uh we got we got to
start giving the members and stuff uh
you know really good value and I think
you guys would enjoy that uh I we I have
something really cool for that you know
but we'll do tournaments uh we'll set it
up man we'll set it up because I I do
want something like that I won't really
be participating in a lot but I'll jump
in there but don't I'm gonna tell you
guys right now don't let me get nice to
head-to-head Fighters because don't let
it don't let don't don't let me be
concise you know first off I did beat
you King I'm gonna bring that up right
now
King I did also beat you a Naruto
no on God and them I just want you there
I just want you to enjoy and have fun
and and to partake in in what it is to
have you know true competition
and once we get it down to the science
when it comes to head to head Fighters
we could do like magic and stuff too but
we need to stick to one thing to really
get it down how exactly we want to do it
we'll do tournaments gotta talk to Saul
you know maybe we'll do some uh some
prizes the number one under the sun yeah
we trying to get that to the number one
under the sun he's gonna walk around
with that belt and it's gonna be like
like your name your name gonna be in
there and our leaderboards yeah the
number one Under the Sun and we gotta
bring back the Box
be challenged by two and three people
we're gonna bring it back to Afro
Samurai days number one under the sun
okay Peterson he said got to love it got
King to play Pokemon
foreign
[Music]
you understand
I'm talking about yo let's play Pokemon
you want nobody showing you their pocket
monster
over over here let me let me show you
what I captured
free candy energy
no he dude
he did it peek at you
and the whole game is called Pokemon
okay you gotta hit the beat bro you're
here
[Music]
we will put that you know definitely
join the patreon uh you know King doing
crazy stuff on there all the time I
think I think me and King gonna start
playing some co-op games and putting it
on there too
can we play some fortnite and I really
like the shoots though
attic you done with the tournament
you're setting up 17 tournaments
there's not really anyone to send them
to because I'm looking at it here
uh so I'm trying to eat
I'm gonna send you guys over too anytime
now hey like you just [__] he's ready
to go down
the Lord stop waking the five people
fighting but you got going on sir
I'm not much working working I'm fading
fast I'm not feeling super great so
we'll see we'll see how we do but uh
yeah and look out for some some things
coming from us next week's a big week
yeah
all week is a big one week I got for
some things and uh yeah yeah that's it
man no doubt Lord King where can the
fine people find you what you got going
on Sir dead sleep I'm dead tired been up
24 hours just bananas but um we got some
other stuff that we working on uh
hopefully when I finish this I can
actually get a chance to see some story
and um in Mortal Kombat maybe that might
happen maybe that man maybe
I can't oh yeah I wasn't part of the
topic I don't understand what's going on
his ass I'm gonna bless myself
[Music]
and if it means acquisition to save them
I'm for it all for it
Microsoft needs to finish this job first
give us a time in between times whomever
whatever long as it ain't 10 I'm good no
they or embrace it embrace
you need to hug themselves they don't
need to be embracing and hugging nobody
when they pockets for holding the
crystal Dynamics they they were they
okay they okay they're going to be good
by the next physical period it ain't
gonna be right so that's it yeah we good
all right cool you already know again
big week this week stay tuned to IOP and
Lord socials our socials probably in the
next day or two right you want to stay
tuned stuff cooking up and um I guess we
could tell them because it's coming up
um for next week Sunday uh part two with
the legend Peter Moore should return we
will should lock that back in we got
more to talk about obviously you guys
gave us tremendous feedback positive
feedback on his appearance and he really
enjoyed himself so yeah we've got some
lingering you know Dreamcast and and of
course um what you call Xbox 360
questions but we didn't even get into
his Chapters at EA and also very fitting
Unity his Chapters at Unity so we will
talk about that and of course for my you
know LSC my skouses you know what I'm
saying we got to talk a little LFC to
man his career is just tremendous
besides being in the video game you know
this man with the owner of a football
club his home football club at one point
so yeah we'll check that
we also have uh footage of his street
fight with eugenaka will have we'll have
yes like the the state of gaming now
because we didn't get really do that
yeah exactly we got some more questions
so again we'll we'll finish off the
remaining questions that we wanted to
save for um Dreamcast 360. also state of
the industry now stuff like we talked
about you didn't know the questions like
that so the laws will cook them up we
may we may entertain a few questions but
we might be able to get everything from
the Realms as far as the patreon this
time but um we're gonna try our best to
to fill that up and uh yeah he's looking
to come back so we're excited so stay
tuned yes oh you said in the battle some
of the back for this little my bro
getting that all Destiny and all the
multi games in but that's all I got
anything else everybody before we get
about it
go in there go in inbox chat and say IOP
yeah tell them that's one of my clan
mates man that's one of my clan mates so
your salute a good dude he always goes
to conventions everybody enjoying Sunday
we out of here peace
thank you
[Music]
foreign